No,
don't,
don't.
I do a show with Diaz in New York.
Boom.
Live.
Uh,
Jamie's given me the na sure.
Look.
Yes.
You and Joey Diaz talking about doing a show in New York where demand,
whereas maybe,
okay,
you want to talk about it?
Yeah,
no need to find one here.
I got a Joey Diaz story.
We're going to do a show with me and Joey and Yo motherfucking Romero and he's
going to talk to him if he gets confused and in Spanish.
Oh,
that's tough because Joey's from Cuba.
Dude.
Are you kidding me?
I was going to translate.
He was Joe.
It's totally Joey's idea.
Joey says,
bro up and talking to them.
I love this fucking guy.
We'd have an amazing podcast.
You wouldn't be,
you'd thrown the questions,
Adam.
If shit gets,
we'd,
I come to him when Spanish.
We'll understand each other better to Berlin ideas with Joey said,
he said,
uh,
he goes,
tell him that I want to be honest.
Podcast,
because he has love for Cuba in under,
he understands Cuban love.
Love it.
I was like that.
All that shit that he was doing a Luke Rockhold after he knocked him out,
like tense up that's in can give me a few minutes.
You just knocked me into frickin.
That's intense.
That gimme a fucking second to get my wits about me and then kiss me on the lips
or wherever the fuck you want to do it.
His ability to just be calm and then explode.
It's very terrifying.
It's only helped by him telling you he loves you.
He's,
he's weren't terrified than never.
It's scary cause he's such a nice guy outside dude.
He is the nicest car.
He's very friendly.
You know the champ though was like,
oh yeah,
that's what you do.
You're Whitaker,
you know.
Whitaker's a monster man.
Kind of go back to that Tim Kennedy fight though.
Man.
Dot.
About stool gate.
Yeah.
That Tim Kennedy fight was crazy.
It was like,
look,
I know what you're doing.
It's very slick.
This is very smart.
I mean,
this is Angelo.
Dundee did that to Muhammad Ali when he fought Henry Cooper in London.
He got crack with a left hook.
Henry Cooper dropped him and he was in real trouble.
They cut the glove,
baby susp cut that glove,
baby.
We got to get the other pair.
Oh,
it's out there in the dressing room.
I'll be right back.
It's all fair in love.
And they go,
oh man.
Yeah,
it ain't the right way to do it.
But you gotta you gotta realize that this guy had gone through the whole amateur
wrestling system as a representative of Cuba.
What the Matt Brown and I did a podcast last week and Matt Brown fat.
He's a great guy and fascinating dude,
man.
Intense smart motherfucker.
But he'll guide people,
get a chance to,
he did he die?
He died and they brought him back.
Yeah.
You know,
we talked about that.
I'm just like you in court McGee,
both of this word creepy thing to you because you both crossed over to the other
side and you don't give a fuck.
How was it?
Whew.
Both guys,
man,
you got to beat them.
They don't beat each other.
Literally have to take,
they don't beat themselves rather.
Yeah.
I mean Matt Brown,
I beaten himself like he's,
he's a human.
What's he doing now?
He is going to fight Carlos condit all that's right.
He's coming back for Wa just he ended,
he ended on that dope ass knocked out of Diego.
The elbow maybe behind the air,
but all's fair a little bit and then you have thought he's going to ride off in
the sunset and they sweat and Carlos condit.
So he was explaining about his camp that he did in Cuba.
It's an amazing story.
Amazing.
He spent like six weeks and cab Brown.
Yes.
His wife,
Susan Cuba.
His white ass was in Cuba with the wrestling team for six fucking weeks for one
of the camps for one of his fights.
He boxed in Cuba against puck,
Cuban boxers and he wrestled.
He lived in a Cuban fighters house.
They had them there and they fed.
Which fight was it that he said?
I try to remember which fight,
if you pull up,
pull up his record.
It was fairly recently,
fairly recently doing that.
He's a bad motherfucker,
dude.
Bad mother fucker.
But he's just trying to get better.
Man.
He's just trying to get better and that's what he figured was the move.
He has one more left though.
Yeah.
Um,
let's be real.
At least if he wants to masters store,
he knows I love him.
He's on the master's tour.
Um,
I think he said it was for the Tim means fight.
I'm pretty sure he said it was the Tim means fight.
Well then after that,
let's get back to in Cuba
by a,
okay.
Who is the constrictor of volcan strict nightmare if Danny and Mike and get you
to the ground.
I don't think most people don't understand what that kind of Jujitsu feels like.
You know,
I've rolled with a few guys that were my size that just went through me work.
I realize.
Yeah,
Jake shields is what are talking about him all the time.
Wrestling with him was like wrestling with a chimp,
Carl Breezy and same thing.
It's like holding onto a chimp.
Like good luck bitch.
You might look like me tonight man.
You know,
it's like you see a guy like maybe just crossfit,
like,
oh that guy looks fucking strong.
No,
there's a different,
there's like a Ben Aspirin strong where it doesn't even look strong.
Just looks like a fit athletic guy and they grabbed you and you're like,
what in the fuck is going on here?
Why can't I move and twist up?
Kind of strong move difference it different kinds of strong.
Damien Maia has got that strong too strong guys.
True.
He does that shit.
The guy like Carlos condit,
correct.
This is a,
he's the motherfucker motherfuckers when it comes to strike map.
That's a terrible fight.
What he did in Neil Magni,
he just kept closing,
closing,
closing.
It was like watching a goddamn snake.
It was like watching a snake take out a deer.
It was terrified.
Slowly get to that back to is tighter and tighter and every time he corrected it
got tighter at Tineye.
You see Neil magni just drown like fuck.
He looked like that zebra in the alligator's mouth.
Just like,
yeah.
You know,
I'll tell you what was equally impressive,
man.
It's hot failed dose on Joseph Neil Magnet.
I was like,
holy fuck.
Did I read that wrong?
I thought Neil Magni was going to give him a real good fight because was cardio
reach,
cardio reach,
foot work,
movement,
discipline sticks to the game plan.
Neil magna is a difficult guy to fight and I Carlos Condit fight,
unless you get him down his Jujitsu's Achilles heel.
Well he,
I mean Damien Maia obviously got him,
but the way dos Anjos got him was like,
holy fuck it.
One 70 dos Anjos is more aggressive and stronger.
It seems to me.
Doesn't it seem he's strong?
He's way better.
He's waving,
that's helping.
He moves,
he has more power.
He's putting his combinations better together and he's just on the lighter side
of being one of those big guys.
So it seems like he's gotten more speed.
He reminds me kind of like Robert Whittaker.
He to me,
the people guys a little small.
He's almost perfect.
Perfect.
Not huge.
He's not muscle bound to do everything really well.
Whitaker stuffed Yoel Romero's takedowns with a blown out knee.
He got his knee blown out in the first round and he's still stuffed.
Takedowns Whittaker is fucking it all up on that Australia training right now.
I think it's another thing where the guy was cutting weight,
making one 70 just struggling man,
just struggling.
I really wish that the way that Ben Astron described how one fcs doing it,
where they're doing this a hydration tasks,
they're doing a hydration test when you weigh in or doing a hydration test like
leading up to the fight and everybody bumped up a weight class and he's now,
he's like at one 85 cause that's really what he weighs.
And not to change subjects but just the,
I listened to that Ben ask and I've always been a huge fan of Ben and I think
it's just such a shame he never fought in the UFC.
I think he beat to anyone in the world,
in the UFC.
I really do.
Well we would like to see at the very least,
I mean maybe if I had to bet on,
and I'm a betting man,
I put some,
a lot of dollars on Ben asking.
That being said,
he's very articulate.
He,
that man needs to do his own podcast and need to do something as far as
entertainment.
He does a restaurant podcast.
He was saying his wrestlers like there's more he could do.
Yeah,
I agree with.
I thought he was brilliant.
He's a brilliant guy and he's just smart and unique like as a person and you can
either appreciate that or not.
That's marketable man.
It is marketable in my opinion.
But it might not pick it cause I don't,
I'm just coming at it from a point of view from as a fan.
I mean I'm a fan,
which,
which is we want to hear,
listen for me,
I,
there's is a no brainer.
You want to see the best versus the best and he has been able to do weird shit
to people and he hasn't been here.
What,
three years dude?
He said his last two fights,
he didn't get hit once.
I didn't get,
he goes,
I haven't been punched in the face in three years.
When I hear that,
I'm like,
that's so arguable.
It's like he's a Floyd Mayweather thing.
Super articulate,
super smart.
Smart Dude.
Good luck and great guy.
He's married.
He's a coach for God's sakes.
Wrestling kids.
I'm not a promoter.
I have no say.
And I don't want it.
I don't want it.
I'm can't you skin like y'all let me know.
Let me Holla at Ya.
He says,
listen,
I know you're stressed it and this guy,
he knows how to promote.
He's a promoter when he,
I don't know Jack Shit about promotion.
I could be wrong.
I might just be such a purist that I want the best to fight the best so much.
I don't give a fuck.
You know the sport,
the sport.
Don't sell yourself short.
I guarantee you we could sell,
been asking if you and I put on a promotion I get into,
I could tosca.
I guarantee I could get into people's heads why this is important.
It's,
it's important.
If the art form is important,
if it's just important to put on a good show,
then you know,
you can always have guys just stand in the middle of the octagon and throwing
lead at each other and let's see what happens.
And you can't just do that.
There's no longevity in that.
But it's very entertaining.
And there have been moments like when Francisco Rivera and John Linacre just
fucking threw down on each other until one guy broke.
That's,
I do recommend anybody fighting like that,
but that shit is crazy to watch.
It's undeniable.
That's going to get the people out of their seats.
That's going to get people freaking out about it.
Just sprinkle that kind of style.
And every now and then that's fun because the sport,
we can't do that I think,
but every now and then when something like that happens,
like with Ricardo Lamas and Max Holloway,
when that's how we pointed down to the ground.
It's like,
come on bitch,
a fight.
He was already wing.
That shows you who max is.
Man,
I'm going to fucking die.
Oh look,
it's bad.
I'm such a fan.
Such a fan would love them with this new showtime show I'm doing it to,
I interviewed Frankie and it's tough for me cause I'm so,
I love Frankie,
but I'm such like a Max Holloway Fan.
It's tough for me not to show the favoritism.
You know what,
man?
I might be a,
I love both of them.
I might be,
I don't Frankie longer.
Yeah,
I'm,
I know Frankie way better.
I'm a giant Max Holloway Fan,
but I have to do this thing that I do where I don't want anybody to win.
I just want to see what the result is.
See,
I don't want anyone to lose.
I'm not good at that.
You're,
you're one of the best in the world.
It's still hard though.
I'm not,
I'm not good at that.
Like I don't want anyone to lose.
Like I love Yoel Romero and I love Luke,
but I've been,
but I,
uh,
I know what those guys feel like when they lose and there's everything on the
table.
I know what for Luke,
how he changed camps and sometimes that's just,
you're on a boat and there's,
and there's holes in then you think if you pal further away from the original
camp,
you know,
fill these holes and it doesn't work like that fresh look.
I mean,
it might have been a good move for him,
but he fought.
You all were marrow.
I mean,
the reality is yellow were marrow is fucking horrifying.
He's horrifying.
Luke can beat him.
He might be able to,
but he also might be able to get hit exactly what you got to hit in that fight
every time they fight.
Dude,
you don't know man.
No,
I'm saying,
I don't know.
I've seen,
I've seen him a,
I've seen a better version of Luke to me as far as skill wise,
besides Whitaker right now he's on another level,
but I look at the roster and to me Luke is the most complete middleweight in the
world.
I can even seem being the light heavyweight champion because Finn like him,
some problems besides gfes in there.
There's going to be some issues for those guys.
Who knows?
Maybe him going,
I mean he's been talking about an inevitable climb to two oh five.
He might be just like Whitaker and just like,
um,
uh,
who else we're talking about?
Y'all failed Dos Anjos yeah,
might be.
He might be a better fighter.
Two Oh five he might be so fucking lean.
The problem there is what made Luke's so great was that swagger,
like the people who were like,
oh,
he's so cocky.
I get that.
I actually want my fighter like that.
I liked how you so arrogant and cocky.
Sometimes people don't gravitate towards it.
But for a guy like
Luke,
he just,
he thrived off that.
And now when I see him,
I,
you know,
when a is Latin in the branch fight,
I didn't see it as much.
I thought there that fight was a little suspect.
Not,
not taking anything away from branch,
but that should have been easier for Luke.
And I see the Yoel Romero fine.
It just,
that killer instinct wasn't there.
He's very,
I know you have five rounds,
but he would let your oil explode and reset when you reset.
You gotta go,
man,
you've got to go.
Branch might not have the best results inside the octagon,
but when it comes to technical skill,
he's a super high level fighter.
His,
his skill level and his capabilities,
I don't think if matched up to all of his performances.
And you saw that when he's attacking Luke,
he's fucking good man.
He put him in real trust and he's not,
he's very,
I'm not saying that it's ground games very good,
but it makes Luke's win even more impressive for sure.
With branches never went in world series of fighting.
He kind of,
you know,
became light heavyweight champion middleweight champion.
He's a monster,
right?
Yeah.
In the UFC.
He just,
he hasn't found his groove yet and he never has right now I don't,
you know,
a lot its level of competition.
You know,
his first fight in UFC was boring and then he'd get Luke Rockhold which no walk
in the park.
So I do think Dave branch's a monster Henzel Gracie blasts a second round in the
UFC.
Right.
Gerald Harris Code with that crazy slam from the guard.
Good career.
Yeah man,
that was crazy.
Gerald Harris is a powerful man.
Monster.
I'm,
I'm just saying with Luke,
it was this swag or what he thought he was the best in the world and was in
Strikeforce is when you got to the UFC when he was champion.
And then in the Biz being fight,
he gets clipped with that left hook and he has problems with the left,
the left side for him.
So you know,
Bisbing lands that knocks him out.
That's short notice fight.
He thought he was going to walk through them and they take that long layoff and
he's,
he's trying to be a male model and you know,
arguing with the UFC,
it's just an in somewhere along the lines that he lost a little bit of swag when
he gets that back.
We're in good form.
Well,
um,
I'm curious to see what his journey with Henry hoofed where that comes up
because they've been,
they,
how about how long have you been together now?
Like a year.
Maybe a year.
Yeah,
he moved out there.
Henry's and interesting coach man,
he's a fucking bad guy.
He's a very powerful guy.
He doesn't have his DC and Cain Velasquez.
And it could be,
and Josh Thompson and this,
these monsters,
you're surrounded by just these monsters.
Who's he's training with and how has he addressed that left side where it keeps
getting hit.
You know what?
Put them out.
You will has left two left,
two left.
That upper cut was like a free for all.
Like mark got gotta get a little closer.
You got to get a little closer.
That would be your marrow.
Just fucking think about it.
It's hitting as fast as you can.
You'll yo male smash.
Literally,
he's punching a humanist hard as they can.
I didn't think it was a bad stoppage because he had his head up when he went
down and you've got to give one guy a chance to hit them now looking at it after
the fact.
You Go,
man,
I wish he didn't get hit with that upper cut.
The fight was already over,
but in the moment,
in realtime,
if it doesn't happen,
we're talking shit.
I hear you.
Unless you ran out four to 40 and I think it's a perfect
stoppage.
I mean,
I think the first one,
you don't really stop it yet.
You got to see what's going on,
but you don't know.
I know.
You never know.
I hear you right.
That when you kind of know,
you kind of,
but after the fact,
we're saying that Frankie Edgar,
let's talk about frank.
Good.
Get that fucking guy's a Zombie.
He comes back from the dead.
He gets cracked by gray Maynard and two fights to the point where it looks like
it's cold.
It's over.
He's been rocked into.
He comes back in the most incredible way.
W when I sit down with them,
we're talking about that.
And you were talking about concussions and CTE because he has kids and stuff.
And I said like that gray Maynard fight.
You know you were concussed and came back yos which crazy.
I don't want to ruin the interview.
That's what's crazy about that.
Brendan is a,
wasn't concuss no signs at all it I'm gonna stop you.
I'm gonna stop you.
Who told you I goes,
didn't even throw up on it.
So that's your sign for not concussed.
She didn't throw up.
I said,
that is such bro signed.
Frankton look at me when I tell you this.
You had brain trauma in that fight,
man.
Fucking telling you,
Bro.
There's no way he didn't.
It's impossible.
I mean,
maybe they'll cover 100% but the,
the fucking heart that it took to come back from that and draw in one fight and
then Kale him in the second latch in brother fucking crazy.
It's crazy.
If you look at Frankie's record,
you know when they tossed him in the eye or Rodriguez is the,
you know these,
these young cats eat some up like Kobiashi.
Now prior to takeoff,
Swanson fight,
Holy Shit does to these young kids,
man,
Brian or tig is a totally different animal though.
Totally different animal.
If he gets a hold of your neck,
you cannot fuck around with that dude on the ground.
We're talking real high level Jujitsu and basically twice I saved by the bell
and then got his neck again.
I don't think people who are watching him are yet 100% aware of what he's
capable of.
He's a fucking killer on the ground,
dude.
He's cinches shit up at one of the highest levels I've ever seen in that.
You should see him in training and practice forever.
And he's a guy where you know the one,
the reasons why he got so good remarry.
He teaches at the Gracie Academy in Torrance,
non stop.
That's a big con.
See Teaching and helping everyone.
He's a great kid,
man.
Monster Dude.
His trial,
one of the best I've ever seen.
It's so quick.
He so fucking nasty off lighting setups.
It's a million setups and the fucking dexterity of his legs man.
And when he sent his shit up,
it's super high level and I've talked about it for a long time with guys with
that high level Jujitsu,
you know a lot of them want to wrestle nonstop and they could try and get gas
debt,
but the rest of it hasn't caught up to their Jujitsu with him.
He's not afraid to jump to guard.
He's not afraid to do flying triangles.
He's not afraid to jump to half guard.
He didn't give a fuck.
That's how,
that's how he was raised into this.
Where Henry Gracie and here on Gracie just,
hey man,
don't be scared off your back.
You're beating dudes.
Yeah.
It's a really interesting combination of boxing because now he's become a very
good boxer.
So his hands,
which are,
he's very comfortable boxing and then guys are trying to take him down.
Right.
And that was the fight before this last one.
Do try to take him down and got Yup.
And he was pulling things out of it,
went late and then he'd pull off these late submissions is guys with ty,
but you give him an inch.
He takes a mile with him.
When I got to of the cubs neck you could see like it's the scariest shit,
a whole nother level of squeeze and technique and the sharpness and everything's
in the perfect place and everything has perfect leverage.
And when he grabs a hold of something,
he cinches it up real and he believes wholeheartedly 100% if you get the goes,
oh this is over.
Yeah.
He's doesn't care.
So many people in training.
He does every high,
high,
I won't say names,
high level dudes and training where you're like holding frog super legit.
That is a fucking dangerous fight for Frankie to,
except on short note how gangsters,
Frankie gangster killing gets latching stories.
It gets different fight Brian or tag as a different violence.
Hands to cause because it,
it's gonna be tough.
Take Frankie down.
But what Brian does have,
he has a size advantage.
It doesn't have a speed advantage and have the wrestling advantage.
I think Frankie puts everything together better as far as killer instinct.
That's his x factor.
I read the other day that Frankie's never been finished.
Wow.
Yeah.
Let me think about credible.
That's incredible.
He's never been submitted.
And he also has that Ricardo Almeida as his Jujitsu coach.
He trains with every day and he's with a Marlin rise to right.
You have Marlon Moraes,
they got Frankie,
they got Eddie Alvarez who's a monster and they're training if free single day O
and n Barboza.
That's their camp.
Oh.
And their leader having to be the best mind in the game.
Mark Henry.
Dude.
That's how all the camp right there.
That's a hell of a camp.
It's ridiculous.
And the,
you know,
for,
for Eddie Alvarez and Frankie and pose on,
it's just like this perfect storm of killers and you have this brilliant mind,
the Einstein of mixed martial arts and Mark Henry,
he was just this fucking savage man.
Yeah,
it's brilliant what they're doing up there.
Yeah.
So one of the hot camps,
right?
I asked frank,
I said,
were you,
were you surprised what happened with Barboza?
And [inaudible] was,
he goes,
dude,
Barboza is a motherfucker to take down.
Like Eddie and I have struggle,
man.
I said,
I think hell good.
Could be this scary,
scary,
scary.
That could be Tony fights on,
I have my number one fight I want to see this year.
There's just people that I think have evolved from generation after generation,
after generation of Grappler,
you know,
and there seems to be something happening with those,
those Russian folks and those Dagestan folks.
And especially him with his dad being this fucking amazing trainer.
He's just just tougher than us.
Joe Tougher.
We're not the same.
Something happens when he grabs a hold of the guy,
so you just don't see it shows his face was like,
what the fuck?
It's getting run over by a freight train.
Just a guy with unstoppable pressure,
constant punches to the face.
You're never getting up.
You feel it.
You know you're never getting up.
And if you do get up,
it's going cost you so much energy to get up.
You're going to be exhausted and then you know this guy can take you down again.
If he takes you down again,
you're three quarters helpless,
three quarters helpless.
Next round is going to be half helpless.
Dexstar round.
After that,
you're basically helpless.
You just tough.
You just surviving on your,
your toughness and your,
you know,
he's going to take you down again.
It beat your face and it's like isis torturing man.
I'd rather just get murked real fast by Francis than fighting.
Could be.
It's a savage,
slow death.
It's a savage slow fight.
But here's the thing,
he's never fought to anybody like Tony.
Tony is so different.
He's so clearly different animal.
He's so different.
He's so dangerous on his feet.
He's hard to take down.
He scrambles like crazy.
He's,
he's well aware of what it takes to protect himself on the ground.
He takes a tremendous shot.
He's got crazy Darcy's,
he pulls Darcy's off on people that are,
that are like,
you know,
he did it.
The Barboza member,
that fucking crazy ass fight and he slaps that Doris on him.
That Darcy's tight son is Darcy's worldclass.
Here's the x factor with Tony and Khabib is to me,
Tony's getting taken down.
I can't sure.
I swear I'd bet my life savings,
he gets taken down.
That's not the fight,
right?
The fight starts once it hits the ground it cause Tony Ferguson off his back is
a monster.
A monster from elbows to this triangle is trending with Kevin Lee.
Yup.
Now Kimberly's different grappling and could be,
but still his setups,
but his elbows,
if you rest,
he's going to whoop your ass from his back.
To me,
that fight happens on the ground.
We got you gotta be careful of WHO's judging that fight because Tony can win
even if he's whooping his ass from his back.
You know what I'm saying?
Is it is entirely possible that Tony could be hitting him and trying to attack
with submissions.
And you don't like doing MMA math,
but they both fart Barboza and Tony was able to finish him.
Tony's has a better resume for sure.
Well he finishes guys,
you know,
I mean he catches guys that are really high level with Jujitsu techniques.
I mean,
especially that Doris super dangerous could be,
could be.
We,
we,
you know exactly what he's gonna do.
He's he,
you know,
his striking isn't world class,
but his grappling,
his pressure,
everything else is worldclass.
We also haven't seen him five rounds,
five rounds with Tony's a tough task.
Men,
it's just totally gets better.
But he thrives in that kind of dog situation where he'd just go and go and go on
to me.
You know,
for Khabib,
if it goes that fourth,
fifth round,
it's,
well,
we don't know.
You know,
that's what,
that's why this fight is so good to me.
That's why it's my number one fight this year.
I swear to God,
if either one of them gets hurt,
I'm going to cry.
You get me so excited.
Yeah,
it seems about,
let me just fucking get your Dick.
How steep a DC.
That's great fight too.
That's a super fight.
Yeah,
that's US fucking super fight.
We talked about all these super fights.
That's a legit super fight.
That is a super fight,
right?
It's such a close fight.
A very decent undefeated heavyweight was a former world champion from
Strikeforce.
It's also when you see DC rest or Volkov and you go,
oh,
there are levels to this shit.
You got time,
you got time,
you got time now you got time to work on your wrestling.
I'm just kidding.
I love you.
Bulky.
But the thing is funny though.
It's funny,
but he actually looked really good.
Really good.
I've been in that clinch with DC and that is no picnic.
Keep threw me around like a rag doll.
He did real good until he didn't do good anymore and then DC did sense when he
said he was going to do it.
By the end of the round,
he had his neck and he just was saved by the bell.
And then when we went to the sac around,
you know,
you could tell what was how ladies decent.
He,
she's amazing.
He's amazing.
That just shows you how fucking great Jon Jones is.
That's,
that's the whole top of the pyramid.
If you're the top of the spear and you go,
what?
Jesus,
how good is this guy?
And John and John Train for one weekend was high off his ass.
Yeah,
listen to how good he is.
He's a fucking wizard.
He's on another level.
Best of all time pds things,
my nominal.
But however,
if you're John,
you're sitting at home right there in your underwear thing about the bad
decisions you've made in your hope,
your hope,
hopefully that you're going to get back in the UFC.
DC's taking your career path because John always wanting to go to heavyweight
wanting to fight steep.
I want to do all the shit.
DC Goes,
oh cool,
hold my beer and then just does this thing.
Dude.
Q,
Imagine how big my Dick Pills.
You know what John?
John comes back at DCP to them.
Do you know Big Qb?
Do you know crazy?
That would be,
that'd be crazy.
Then they fight it heavyweight.
Well,
they're going to fight heavyweight.
You think so?
Yeah.
Dcos that belt cow.
Or there's a 95% chance that Jon Jones fight in the UFC in 2018 so you're saying
it a chance.
Tell me there's a chance.
That's his agent though.
You know what I'm saying?
That's his agent,
Jim Carey,
Tony,
me.
There's a chance you can't really listen to agents,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
That guy,
first of all,
do you think is going to be the next rock?
He's full of Shit.
You know,
if you've talked to him on the greatest thing walking this earth,
it is entirely possible that he accidentally took the,
and people are saying that I'm being paid to say this and I'm gonna tell you
right now.
Yes.
He's never paid me to say anything other than the truth.
The reality about it is they don't know what he took.
They don't know what happened.
They don't know how he got it.
And the theory that I talked about is just a room that was going around that
someone was trying to explain one way could have happened and it's through
tainted creatine that was backed up by an Novitsky,
the golden snitch,
who's his actual employee of the UFC and also we say,
you're not paid.
Why do UFC does not pay you to say anything on this podcast?
No,
you're a commentator.
They're not willing to say,
to their credit,
they've never tried.
They've never,
ever,
ever tried.
They know better,
but if they ever talked to me about something,
it's something we all agree with.
Like you know,
like maybe Dana and I have,
I have conversations about like,
this is a big fight on,
are you pumped for this?
I'm like,
fuck dude,
I can't even wait.
Are you kidding me?
Kept putting like,
dude,
I've talked to him about it in the past d once you start insulting him and
fucking with them,
he's like,
I'm busy.
He's forgiving.
No,
you got to talk to him.
He paid me anymore.
No,
he does.
I hope he doesn't.
He probably think if we can you do.
If Ben and him sat down and I could be there,
maybe I can help be the middleman.
I would do that.
I had 100% be willing to do that.
You know me,
I want us to go through the Reebok.
They,
yeah,
yeah.
I think Ben is,
uh,
under,
under utilized and not understood.
An underappreciated.
That's what I think it's a real shame to cause th th the father's time,
you know,
and he can't wait that long.
Did you see what he's into?
Cars,
cough.
You see what he did to Lima?
These are top flight.
Super powerful guys.
He ragdolled some and Cubbie once cause this fight 55 and go to 70.
What's up son?
And you know,
he had that interesting conversation,
uh,
about when he fought,
Jay Hiran,
which is his toughest fight in Bellator split decision.
But he said he wasn't wrestling.
He said he fucked up.
Oh,
he's just trying to strike striking and his wrestling was off.
And I was like,
that's incredible that someone is good as him.
Still needs to be constantly doing it to stay sharp.
You forgot what got you,
got you to the dance.
I'm like,
that's amazing.
And so ever since then he's concentrated on his wrestling and just taking
everybody down.
Like when he concentrates on his wrestling and he's constantly doing it,
that's the way to do it.
And even uh,
Curtis Blade,
the text you,
I'm like,
dude,
this Australian car.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah,
it was fucking hate on it.
Get it over with.
But he,
that card was amazing,
but Curtis blade goes,
listen man,
you guys want to Boomi hate to tell you I don't enjoy getting punched in the
face.
I'm not trying to get punched in the face.
Not by me,
by anyone.
I'm just trying to get paid.
How could it's Curtis plates Chins the beard dude.
He took some shots.
Mark Hunt,
put it on him,
man lasted him.
He was almost out of it and he gets the double like,
fuck yeah,
that's what you're supposed to do.
This is fighting.
That's exactly what you're supposed to do.
And I'm biased as fuck.
Cause Curtis from my,
from my old camp and I see those guys.
I talked to him,
they told me how much of a monster is,
and I love Mark Hunt.
I didn't want anyone to lose that fight.
When I see Mark Hunt taking down,
it's Mark Hunt to me is like the white rhino,
the last white,
you know what I'm saying?
He's the last remaining white rhino.
We got to protect this guy.
Don't give them the fucking just wrestler.
He's a legend.
Don't give him that guy.
Give Him Francis.
Let's see how that plays out.
Give him,
you know,
not jds,
but you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
How dare you give him a fucking Juco national champ and send it to Australia.
How dare he almost won by knockout though in Mark's hard to take down.
I think it was a good test.
I think it was an important test.
Look,
they tried to do the same thing with Derek Lewis that gave Derek Lewis at
tested,
Mark Hunt.
Mark Hunt,
shut them down and stopped him.
Derek Lewis,
one of the best fucking heavyweights in the division,
but one of the best heavyweights,
not one of the best wrestlers.
Right,
but he still is.
One of the best guys,
one of the,
uh,
he's a knockout artist and a,
a promising up and coming guy that given to mark on,
he cannot get past mark.
Hi
Chris Blades.
Not really if it happened,
I'm yet,
but it's happening in Australia with all his fans.
They're from New Zealand.
Dude,
that's a big fight for him.
It's a smart fight.
I fight for who?
For both guys.
Mark Hunt One,
if he connected with a couple shots more or have Curtis was,
wasn't as tough as good as he is.
He could have knocked at anybody at that night for four.
Curtis,
it's a smart fight,
right?
For Mark has smart fight.
She really,
he's already a legend,
but if he wins the way almost one by nine [inaudible] in Australia,
it jumps you up even further.
Not really.
He's ranked fifth,
but the excitement of the Perth crowd,
you're good as your last fight.
If he had to Kaos in a row like that to be,
that's big to me.
Style stylistically,
it's the bad macho.
I understand what you're saying,
but he's 40 and he's legitimately one or two big wins away from another title
shot.
Think about what you have,
right?
You have DC versus steep pay,
whoever fights at who they gonna fight next.
Mark Hunt knocks out.
Hold on a second.
He knocks out of him and then he knocks out someone next like who could it be
where you could try Overeem again.
But the problem with Omar,
him fighting for the title again is he just lost this deep pay by knock out and
then he just lost a Francis [inaudible] down there as well.
Yeah.
So yeah,
you've got some fucking real interesting fights,
but all it would take was Mark Hunt to beat one of those top guys and he's in
consideration.
Again,
there's a small pool there,
super so small.
That's why Overeem keeps getting shuffled back to top.
As tough as he is and it's not taking anything away from them,
there's not a lot of,
there's not a lot of the licensee and fed into the top tiers of the group.
No new blood really well.
It's hard.
It's a fucking hard division to find.
Talented guys I think have the most tough called division.
Well heavy,
I think.
I think heavyweights better often light heavyweight.
Look at light heavyweight.
It's like Jesus Christ.
That's a shark tank light.
Heavyweights got a lot of crazy shit going on right now,
right?
Like what happens if DC loses or leaves rather Belton bounce?
So if he goes to heavyweight and stays in heavy winds,
bounces and think of that man,
this is crazy,
right?
Imagine Cain going to tool five.
That's not happening.
Maybe he's too old.
He's gonna fight heavyweight one for them.
Talk hosts.
Come on.
Kate [inaudible] seen that and seen that show.
That dude eats.
He gets down to that Mexican.
I don't blame a man.
He's earned it.
However,
Katie,
it'll fight.
He's not going to fight for the title.
By the way.
He's going to fight once this year and then hopefully a title fight.
But I think what they're planning on is DC beat Steve Bay.
Vacates the bell and then Kenny know fight for the interim belt towards the end
of the year or being in the early next year.
Damn steep paid is not going to hear that kind of talk.
People just loves to overlook steep Emile Chick.
It's fucking crazy.
Look,
look at the heavyweight division though.
It's fucking land of the dinosaurs and then light heavyweight.
Well,
Francis is terrifying for everyone in the planet other than steep Amy.
Oh Shit.
No,
no,
I,
so Francis Woods would lose 'em back off the train.
So Francis,
you're off the Goddamn and laugh.
That train.
I didn't know.
He can't wrestle at all.
I think he was saying no was like,
how do you spell wrestling?
Listen.
So Curtis blades smoked him.
Cain Valasquez smoke some smoke.
Who?
Francis?
Yes.
All Day.
Really.
So you think Curtis blades when they fought the first time just wasn't ready.
She didn't remember that I got stopped via doctor.
Stop it right in the second round.
I think he goes,
hold up.
You have zero wrestling.
You just hit mitts and lift weights and talk to employees at the UFC institute.
Fuck yeah,
I'm going to rustle your ass.
I want to point out that I do not agree with that assessment.
I'm sure he trained his wrestling.
I'm sure he was in the best shape it could be.
It's not what he told me.
Nothing.
I think he burned down the first round.
I mean I've watched it.
He's definitely need some more.
No technique.
Yes.
Wrestling there from the very get go.
If his,
his sheer strength got them through some of those take downs,
but you look at his hand placements,
hips,
it's not there now it can come.
It's a,
it's a tough business to be and then try and pick that those skills up and you
look at the that list.
You know Dick Lewis,
he can,
he can double like your ass con ops a good matchup.
Curse blades.
Nightmare came last.
His nightmare for BC over doom.
Fucking nightmare.
I'll stover and can wrestle if he wants to.
Steep Bay,
obviously nightmare.
We saw what he did to him.
The thing is he's so fucking powerful that every one of them could get 90
knighted with one shot.
The sport's evolved my bills.
If sport is to be world champion [inaudible] world champion,
but you're looking at it through the eyes of someone who fought steep aimia
chick,
right?
He fought steep Emile chick.
Steve Bay figured him out.
Steve Bay beat him.
Right?
But Steve Bay is a very,
very unusual character and there's some shots that he got hit with,
hit with and not fight that a lot of dudes would not have been able to take.
I agree with that.
However,
if for Burrito gets you on the ground,
and I promise you if you get down that Loftin,
he would have choked Francis unconscious.
That's a different animal on the ground that have so his cane,
no cane Khe Sanh he'll beat you up on the ground.
He,
you know,
he's not a big finisher.
He's gonna do,
he's gonna fuck you up and he's gonna worry out.
It's not a huge finish.
You don't look for submissions.
France or I'm sorry for doing well fucking get a hold of your neck and electric
emission.
And then think about Cain,
his ground and pounds for Roche.
Roche's super accurate.
And the,
the,
the reps he puts in Bang,
Bang,
Bang.
You know that he breaks you were,
Steve Bay is very controlled.
He's going to take you down,
even give a fuck,
he's going to wear you out.
Yeah.
Cain has a crazy output like his outputs disturbing nuts.
You know,
you w you watched the,
the,
the sheer volume and the pace of the takedowns and chaining takedowns together
and beating you up on the way down.
You're like,
wow.
Um,
uh,
Javier Mendez said this once we were,
were in the back and it was him and crazy Bob Cook.
And I was like,
dude,
I go,
I think he was just,
it was,
I forget who it was that he fought,
but I said,
I think he was just expecting to ride the storm out,
you know,
like,
cause he just couldn't keep up with Cain.
And uh,
Javier goes,
the storm doesn't ever go away.
He goes,
that storm is there forever.
Like you don't understand,
there's no ride in this door.
You got to fucking just care down and tried to match it.
He's like that.
I mean,
they even talk openly about it.
Like he's a freak.
Like he'll take three weeks off,
come back.
He just runs through the buddy nuts.
There's something going on.
Unless you fly to Mexico.
Yeah,
there's something going on.
Wow.
That was a fucking mess,
man.
Nobody could do that.
Nobody.
Even cardio cane can't go to 7,000 feet without being there for a while.
It's just,
it's,
it's just think about that relentless,
I don't mean in a rough count.
So he met the real relentless approach in dcs fights.
Very similar against Steve Bay.
And that,
to me,
that's where I look at.
I see when it first came out,
like,
oh my God,
it's a super fight.
Let me think about this.
What about Laura?
My initial thoughts always go,
what's my initial thoughts?
What most people are gonna think?
Well,
Steve Bay has knocked out power.
His wrestling's good.
He puts everything together well,
but the cardio of dcs,
give me an issue.
If DC can get past that third round,
that's a big tremendous cardio.
But so does bay.
And here's the other thing.
Does he think about steep bay?
What we was able to do with Francis,
he caught Francis who is the most dangerous guy,
the division standing up and the most dangerous guy in terms of making a
distance down.
Yeah,
hands down,
hands down.
He caught him with some strong shots,
tagged him several times and now think of the difference in size,
which is Steve Bay in DC.
You,
you got a guy who he's,
he's finding out it doesn't hit as hard.
DC's definitely formidable in the feet and he showed that in the,
the Vulcan fight,
he cracked full Khan.
He's,
his standup is very good,
but he's not absolutely terrifying with his punches.
His technician,
right?
Well he has a technician.
I think he gets away with something where we were Ho ho he'll leave his hips and
I'll pull backs.
Heavy weight.
You can be a little trouble now saying that he is undefeated as a heavyweight
so,
well,
I was,
I was very impressed with his hands and the Vulcan fight.
He was the one that was landed.
She too,
he played that game right.
And Volcker,
his fucking dangerous.
His standup is very,
very dangerous,
so I was,
I'm impressed with him.
I think he is a technician,
but he's like five 11 Steve Bay six for Steve Bay's long and he's very good at
knocking out heavyweights.
I'm thinking the way Steve Bay knocked out for doom,
the way Steve Bay was able to crack Francis Overeem.
He's a beast.
Santos,
but he did to him about what he did to Mark Hahn.
Yes.
Our Lawsky what he did to our lab,
skinny dude.
He's a beast.
You guys heavyweight of all time in the UFC bright.
Now you have to say yes because he won the title three.
He's the only three times.
Yeah,
he's a fucking animal.
So you got a tall order for DC.
It's interesting because of his wrestling and it's just ability to figure out
how to win and how good he looked in the Vulcan fight,
but Volk on its deep bay are not the same.
Steve Bay is the heavyweight fucking champion of the world and know for whatever
reason people seem to be able to,
I don't want to look past him.
I don't know why.
I do it too.
And I see because a buddy of mine,
Steve Bay's a buddy of mine,
you look past them now.
It's very strange.
Like I,
I was literally you and I did the Wilbur together when the fan questions,
how steep a beat a fucking Francis I went come out in a singlet and do not
strike it all.
Like just,
I'm scared for a man.
But you look at it,
Steve Bay just pulls it off,
man.
He's a winner.
That's what it is.
As straight winner is a winner.
He knows how to win.
But you know,
you know who's a winner and as an Olympian and to me,
besides John Jones is the greatest fault time.
Daniel Cormier.
Yeah.
Something,
some other Garrett and [inaudible] but also at heavyweight.
He's going to come in
around two 30 right.
And then his leverage and he's,
he's talked strong that fucking the clinch.
So there's division one wrestling,
Steve Bay,
Cleveland State.
Then there's Oklahoma state wrestling,
Olympic wrestling.
You're talking about WWE Mba to NBA all stars.
This is a good,
complete difference then.
Yeah,
he's been asking for God's sake.
You could see it.
I mean,
when remember when he fought Dan Henderson,
you're like,
Holy Shit.
Where we picked up Josh Barr net slammed him.
What he did to Dan Henderson.
That was,
that was insulting.
I see.
That's a Goddamn Lechon Dan Harris,
who's also an Olympian.
Yeah,
I know.
And he picked them and spiked on his head like he was a four year old.
Rue him around like you never saw anybody can respect.
And then he showed respect the Anderson Silva.
Well that was a fight Anderson took on short notice.
Remember?
Otherwise he probably wouldn't have got paid.
It's Jillian.
How are you gonna Spike Dan Hatch and the Goddamn American beauty and about two
kisses him for let's just buy that.
That's Josh Barnett.
All three.
But Josh did have a bucket handle and people,
this is Dan Henderson.
This is,
that's insulting.
That's rude to say.
He's just so strong.
That's Gustin who?
Six fucking strong deez nuts,
man.
It's not just technique.
The techniques.
Amazing.
You gotta be so strong to be able to do that to Josh Barnett.
That is crazy.
He flips through the air and he's literally throwing them around like
literally.
That's how I,
that's how I throw the tires and the gym and that's difficult.
That's difficult little on it to me,
body,
I'm such a fan and you know what?
I like that.
What's crazy is DC slowly becoming the face of the UFC,
becoming this world like star,
he's becoming a superstar.
I think people are starting to realize,
first of all,
he's a really good guy.
Like a really,
really good,
genuinely good as it is.
Beautiful.
There's no app person and he's a fucking beast man.
He's so tough.
And he throws duvets around like right there when he did his dad right now,
and I did what?
He did,
dead.
Harrison's fucking salt in DC sued the kid gets a hold of Josh Barnett and he's
like,
nope,
dude.
Going down.
I don't give a fuck what you think.
Oh,
you're the war master.
Very cool.
Check that out.
Congratulations.
You're on your back.
It's just how he does it,
man.
Look at this.
Boom.
His wrestling is just so many notches above most of the people that fight,
which makes you even more fucking impressed with John Jones.
Oh Dude.
That's what makes me even more impressed.
Jon Jones down.
You bring,
when you bring John Up to me,
it's happy if the hurt John took him down and try and talk him down was if I had
one of those men in black things where he breaks people's memory.
I did race.
Everyone's John's fight.
Dude can't erase the best.
He's the best.
I know.
Look at his performances like the fact that he was thinking about how God damn
good DC is and think of John Head kicked him and stunning him and then putting
them away and don't remember first.
Right.
John took him down.
There's a picture of DC literally like,
Oh shit.
He's getting Aa.
Yeah.
What made you said after the fight he really underestimate how strong he was.
Oh my God.
John's on many levels,
many levels past what most people understand and,
and think about all the distractions,
all the shit that guy has been through and he still is able to perform at that
level.
All the crazy shit almost went to jail,
the fucking crash,
get to a pregnant lady's car,
the all the fucking craziness cocaine,
all of that.
I'd be willing to bet if you gave Jon Jones literally like,
hey bro,
you're going to have to fight in three days.
I would still put my money on John to be anyone in the world.
He's so crazy.
This is something special man.
John,
something special,
depressed,
whatever the hell he is.
I'll take John,
he's something special and you know,
you really see it in the fights where he's losing.
That's what you see how good he is.
How about the guest and fight with like barely trained him,
just showed up and like did work.
When when I say did work,
you're talking about with the greatest light heavyweight fights of all time and
it was a five round war war war and John took over in the last half of the
fight.
It's not.
Yeah.
And then how about the veto or fight?
He gets his arm basically bent sideways and then submit [inaudible] submits
them,
gets out of the arm bar,
which looks fucking horrific.
The arm bar,
it's like you see how far it's bent and you're just thinking about what his
elbow must be doing right now.
Popping and cracking and he still didn't tap and then he went on to coach the,
the ultimate fighter.
Remember he couldn't use his arm,
right?
Like he,
one of the reasons why he wanted to coach us cause he couldn't train for a
while.
It's nuts,
man.
Dude,
he monster wouldn't tap,
he wouldn't tap.
You get his arm bent sideways.
I know a lot of guys do that,
don't get me wrong,
but you got to understand a lot of guys that are as talented as John can't get
through adversity.
It's one of the things that makes him special.
Thrives in it.
Well,
yeah,
when the chips are down,
he's not giving up.
There's no giving up.
It's not happening.
He almost prefers it to,
I think you told John,
hey,
on this,
come back,
we knew 12 week camp ease your back into your eat.
Right.
Everyday.
There's no hookers,
there's no dick pills.
I,
I don't think it helps him.
I think he needs a little bit of chaos.
I've known other absolute like ultimate winners who they need to look with chaos
when everything's going perfect.
There go,
Whoa,
we need,
we need to throw a wrench into it.
Well maybe you might be right,
but I just got to think that just the actual chaos of fighting,
if treated correctly could fill that void in between while he's doing these
training camps.
I think he still hasn't reached his potential.
I think we've made it be seen in a couple of fights.
We had a great training camp and he didn't fuck around and he didn't party thing
get caught.
Yeah.
Well whatever it is,
maybe he,
we don't know.
I don't know what he's doing.
I don't know.
I don't know if he goes through cycles of party and we know he's a wild
motherfucker.
Fuck.
Self proclaimed,
but you have to be clean.
He says is,
wow,
motherfucker,
we note.
We know he's a wild mother fucker,
but he's also that wildness is one of the reasons why he's so fucking good.
You have to have the whole thing.
You got to have the whole thing.
He is an artist and a lot of ways.
You got to have the wildness,
you got to have
the physical talent and you got to have the brained understand pathways to be
creative,
to take chances to do things.
Wild risks like flying knees on Shogun or spinning elbows on Stephan Bonner,
and this is a whole like when he's fairly new to striking,
right?
You also got to be able to have that bit of craziness where you can only train
for two weeks and there's still go in there with a world class athlete like a
Ryan Bader,
a dustbin,
and being still have the confidence scale.
I'll figure it out.
I know,
I know.
He's been trained 12 weeks and he's one of the best in the world.
I got this.
That's a different switch that 99.9% of professional athletes don't have,
but a man gin it.
Full dedication,
full perfect diet.
Now I got to do that Shit,
man.
I did that to the guy.
You think he wants that?
You know what I'm saying?
I don't know.
I gotta let him free like who don't put her in the fucking container.
People look at them.
Let them out in the ocean.
Let me do it.
Never got released.
He didn't know how to live in the Wild Burro weld.
All John knows I live in the wild and you want to toss him into the fucking
container and bring them to put them in a blazer and some Khakis and no dick
pills.
You know what I'm saying?
Like let them live,
man.
Is it a crime to take take pills in a little joke?
Delmon the problem's not that.
The problem is is he getting enough recovery?
So these training enough to reach his full potential and what is more important?
Is that more important or is it nurturing the wild nature that lets you do crazy
shit.
If there's a balance,
he should be able to do both.
Maybe he's not hurting anyone doing coke,
doing dick.
But as you get older and your body gets more and more tired from war,
right.
I mean think the battles that guy's been in.
That's the nature of the beast though.
That's everyone.
But that's going to be a problem if he's not fully dedicated as time moves from
one.
If you are fully dedicated like a Cain Velasquez,
he has a cage around his spine now.
You know what I'm saying?
Like no matter what,
it's going to take its toll on you.
If you perform at your best,
you partying to three in the morning and then shut up training drunk,
drunk,
that's your,
that's your path,
man.
We shouldn't put these guys in boxes and forced them to live like this and you
have to do this and this is the way to do it.
John Goes,
that's not my way,
man.
Oh really?
It's not.
No,
I'm actually undefeated.
Yeah.
My only losses to mark Hamill from whooping his ass so bad.
It's true.
That's my only loss.
So you wanted me to do what I gotta act like the rest of these guys.
That's not fair,
man.
It's bullshit.
That's an interesting perspective.
I like what you're saying.
Not everyone fits into these boxes that they want to put them in.
He's not hurting you.
One.
What he said,
the problem is you hear about someone partying too much and he always wore,
they're like,
man,
are they happy?
I know they're trying to feel out there partying.
What are they doing?
You ask him why he's hiding and say,
hell yeah,
I need the balls deep in these dime pieces cause he's the best fighter in the
world.
Glass.
Michael Ervin,
who party too has some legendary parties.
The Dallas cowboys had the,
they had a White House,
they call it the White House.
The all three of them.
The most famous players chipped on on a match and they call it the White House.
And every week they would throw the most epic parties of all time.
You know what?
Some of the best teams of all time.
It's
true.
Why do they get check these boxes off.
Let him have a little fucking fun.
They're not like you nine to fivers.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Look,
you got a real point there.
The only argument against it would be if there was someone in his division that
was like him but was dedicated.
There's not,
there's not right now.
I mean there's,
even if they are,
then there's a BC who puts up the best fight with them,
but he's lost twice,
second time and fabric and he's dedicated his foc dedicated as fuck.
Yeah.
They don't have to be the same to get in that cage,
man.
It's not fair.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
I know it's an interesting point of view because like is he so talented that he
can get away with not training as much as everybody else or is it just that his
ability to say fuck it and his ability to just not give a fuck and be wild,
be accountable.
One of his talents,
that's a talent that most people don't have.
So and along with obvious physical talents.
Correct.
He was born with his God given talents and he's born with this cowboy attitude
and that for him that works.
There's no mental coach.
There's no,
he doesn't need any of that.
It's good point.
Yeah.
See,
it's almost like he needs a Frasier,
right?
Like Ali needed Fraser sugar needed Tommy Hearns or Roberto Duran,
they needed each other.
They do.
They need each other and we can just,
I bet DC did bring out the best in him and that's what he said.
Yeah,
that DC brought out the best in him,
but he needs someone else now he needs someone else.
Maybe it's steep bay because,
yeah,
because if he,
if he fights DC again,
boy,
you can make that fight for sure.
Especially if DC wins the heavyweight title.
But yeah,
John Just Kod em in the last fight and for DC emphatic and I know d and l,
the fighter in DC in the winter in DC,
he wants that fight again,
especially at headquarters.
You said,
wait champ,
I get that.
But as a DC fan,
I,
I don't want to see that.
Some guys just have your number.
It's just not in the cards.
I,
I may be me.
It,
he's not John's equal.
John goes to another level and he fights them.
But maybe it's a steep,
steeper,
maybe it's for do I think for doom.
John's a tough fight for John.
Steve Bay's a beast of a fight for him.
I'd love to see John First.
Francis.
Yeah,
maybe.
Maybe.
Maybe there's one of these heavyweights who out there who can control,
you know,
cause John's not knockout artists too,
so he has to be in the for five rounds with these super heavyweights who hit
like a Mack truck.
You know,
John does get hit.
So there's these varies.
You know,
one of the craziest things about John is he's not really a knockout artist and
we love him,
but yet he knocked out DC with a head kick.
Yeah,
that's right.
And dcs impossible to fucking knock out.
Yeah.
He's never been knocked out.
Um,
maybe John Sitting on his punches and kicks better now.
But what's amazing is how terrifying is without having ever done that or done
that,
but not done it to the extent of some of the best guys in the division,
like Jimmy Manawat or one of those guys just vicious,
vicious,
like you doesn't have that Anthony Johnson power and like,
Oh,
if this lands,
it's over with John,
he's gonna slice you up.
Right?
He's going to break your will or your get wrestling.
He's gonna Wrestle you.
Oh,
you're just too black league veto.
He's gonna Submit Ya owes Demir hits harder than him.
A lot of guys hit harder than him.
For sure.
Ryan Bader probably hits harder.
Did to Ryan Bader.
Yeah.
Well,
he's just a combination of things,
you know,
fighting spirit,
indomitable fighting spirit.
It's just that motherfucker does not give up crazy wrestling talent.
Super strong.
Just knows how to win and has a checkered past.
But when it comes down to it,
he might've had,
might not have the 12 week camp,
might an eight hours of rest.
Pride in eat right.
Might be balls deep in a whole bag of gummy bears.
I still,
when he shows up,
he's gonna fuck you up.
He's on another level.
He needs he,
it's almost like he needs someone on his level and there's a few of those guys
out there like is there outliers?
Man Outliers.
They in the sport might not see one yet.
It might.
It might be coming up.
It might be a guy that's on the way.
He might be emerged in a year and a half from now.
It's just what happens with these guys.
I mean we can never pretend that the talent that exists today is the only town
that we're going to see in a year from now.
It's crazy and I think those guys are,
they're going to be better,
man.
Everybody's going to be better if they're all bunching.
Could be.
They're all watching Tony.
They're all watching Barboza.
They're watching Ben Asker and they're watching all these people.
Everybody's just getting better.
It's just getting better.
But notice every guy you mentioned besides Tony is a specialist who's great at
one thing.
Every guy you just Miss Mencia.
There's something to be said for a specialist man.
There's something to be said for a person who's like a go cart Saki,
who you just don't want to fucking stand up with him.
It's just too high level.
I'd watch him and John John would take him down.
He's not ready for John Seconds.
No,
but I,
I'll,
I'll pay you to watch that guy fight every year.
I'll pay to watch him fight anyone in the world,
but hurt for crises.
But if [inaudible] can get his,
his wrestling skills and continue to hone them,
he's a guide late brother.
True.
But he's a guy like a cro cop who is so explosive and powerful that if you just
get him some takedown defense,
it's going to be fucking hard with the cage to take that guy down.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
Cro cop became like very short,
very quickly.
He went from being a guy who fought Vandelay Silva,
a special rules match.
Remember beat some standing up and then they had some deal where it can only go
to the ground for like 30 seconds or something like that.
I'm Japanese.
Weird Shit.
Yes.
By the time they fight,
the second time he destroys them.
I mean destroys it,
just beat him senseless and then merge into that wrestling world.
And he also,
you know,
if,
if we're doomed before he was even fighting was his Jujitsu coach.
You know that.
So for Dumas,
so as dean lister,
yeah,
so he brought all these guys in so you can learn the ground,
you know,
but he's also younger than go kinda at the time.
So when I see guys like,
and I'm not hating on people like,
Oh,
you hate on Francis,
I don't hate them.
What happens is when you're,
he's number,
it's still ranked number one in the world.
When you're Francis do you rank number one in the world?
There's no gimme fights,
there's no warm up.
The UFC can't do it.
So you're at this level where you don't really have time to make up for it.
You can't take three years off at the age of 34 and learn how to wrestle.
It's,
you don't have that time.
You just don't have that time.
And it's a bummer.
It's like into the NFL,
playing for the Patriots.
And can only go to the left with routes and go on.
I'll try and learn to the right like,
well,
what are you talking about man?
You can't go both fucking weights like no,
but I'll learn like look,
get the fuck out.
Or we got someone to do it,
man.
You know it's a weird reference.
I'm sorry.
No,
I know what you're saying.
Fucking where Jamie got it.
I know,
I know what you're saying.
I kind of get it.
And it's someone who's not a riot.
Yeah,
I totally understand.
Um,
but seeing as this guy five years ago couldn't do anything right.
Five years ago,
he just gets to MMA.
Five years later,
you see about Francis.
Yeah.
Five years.
In five years,
he becomes a number one heavyweight contender,
a terrifying betting favorite over the champion who if he wins,
breaks the record of the most ever successful title defenses in UFC history.
So he,
even though he's won two title fights in a row,
gets worldclass competition.
Still underdog five years,
five years in.
So just imagine if this guy has a kind of appetite for learning and,
and,
and continuing to grow that he showed there.
Think about GSP.
GSP had zero high school wrestling,
zero college wrestling started picking up quick.
I was trained with Russian nationals,
they were up in Montreal,
did a lot of technical work,
learn the basics of it and as the kind of athlete that GSP is,
he just started implementing it.
Started getting good at Francis would have to do something like that.
Literally half who or you know at the heavyweight division,
maybe he does it and he's just that guy,
you know that he knocked people out and that's what he wants.
I don't know,
oh he wants to be the best man,
but I think that he can be,
but there's going to be some guys that are going to be able to take him down for
him when you say some guys and they could do it for the next 10 years.
That when,
when he's always going to be able to get taken down.
There's a certain level where even if you hire fricking,
you know Ben asking is your coach,
he can't teach you enough to make up for those gaps against the DC.
Again to Cain Velasquez,
not against DC,
even a against a blade's,
a Curtis play to the national champion.
Well,
Curtis plays is also a big guy.
Curtis blades is a big alcohol,
very powerful athlete and really good wrestler.
So he's not the same level as Daniel Carme but he's a much bigger man.
Those shots that he took against hunt believe holy fuck dude,
that was going to pause.
We'll him,
he's ready to drop.
I'm like,
he's going to drop.
God damn.
He didn't drop and then he took him down.
I was like,
why Texas cornermen Cody Donald,
my best friend,
they're like pro.
If you tell him to throw his right hand again,
I'm going to fucking bust.
He should literally Double Jab and get in to the legs.
He needs to quit.
Told him that slow right hand cause market such a high level striker.
He sees it coming from a mile away.
It's so amateur.
He is.
He so him and Francis,
if you could put those together,
you have the best heavyweight of all time.
You have one guy is fucking phenomenal.
It striking,
you have no yet phenomenal at wrestling,
can't wrestle,
can't strikes.
You put them together and you got this fucking transformer Ninja turtle who just
fucking does war.
Curtis can strike.
You just can't
strike at the same level that mark on has,
but what he can take is a fucking tremendous challenge.
Huge for now,
for as long as it lasts and will it last against a guy like Francis in the
second fight?
I'll tell you this,
I'd rather be,
if I had to pick,
I love both guys.
I'd rather be in Curtis played,
choose them.
Francis.
I will say that when I have a group,
I have a grappling background because what happens if,
if I'm a striker,
Francis I can't control if you want to take me down,
right?
Frances can control,
I'm sorry.
Curtis can control whether the fight goes the ground or not.
He dictates where the fight goes.
Francis does nurse round.
France does not.
After the first round.
The only thing that could change.
Now here's the thing,
is Francis putting on any weight due to strength training or is he just that big
up?
He used to fight at two a five you know that he did.
He fought it to a five one 13 no,
I don't know.
Look it up to me.
I'm pretty sure he used to buy it to a five how is that even possible?
I have no idea.
Maybe someone's weird African American years.
I'm pretty sure he thought to a fight and my batshit crazy here.
Two Oh five what?
That tool?
Five in African stones,
which is really to city.
You know what?
I'm a stone is like English proper English.
So weird.
What is it?
I think it's like,
is it 1314 1212 I think it's 12 I'm half English.
Deeper screaming.
How come you don't know that?
But we know who your president is.
1414 gift officer.
Yeah.
Let's not call things number 13 that's an unlucky number.
They would never use 13 I said 12 that's good.
I was at a hotel the other day.
It didn't have a 13th floor.
Most of all,
don't force them.
Don't also grow up believing it.
It's dangerous.
It's as Dubin.
They're coddling to people so bad.
You take Friday the 13th off for God's sakes.
Thank God it's the day of the 13th floor.
People are so weary,
man.
People are super goofy with shit like that.
They get some people get real goofy.
Strange man.
Dude.
How about your boy Tyson?
Pedro Dude.
Fucking Tyson.
You get my seat on Jerry,
by the way,
man.
Anytime I'm here.
Come on.
Yeah,
come on down.
Come on down.
His Shell and mine.
I'm a huge fucking fan.
He's a bad motherfucker and he's a fun guy to add mother fucker.
All Blah strangers put on a show.
It's a merging hotspot.
Well it's been a hot spot in a long time,
but Australia like John Wayne,
par for Moy,
Tai,
obviously Ray Sefo and New Zealand and um,
mark leader.
Yeah,
and a few other guys too.
You got Robert Winter Australian.
Yeah,
that whole part of the world.
Pedro Monster and then the heavyweight,
the big heavyweight.
Forget his name.
He fought in monster.
Dan Hangman from a New Zealand.
Yeah man,
they got a lot of monsters.
That's killers.
You got killers there.
Have you done shows in Australia?
Yeah,
I had a good time man.
Such a great Melbourne.
What's up there?
UFC weigh ins for Ingando.
Okay,
so you started yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But that's what best I could find when someone,
I'm,
I'm most proud of someone told me you football cause he that would mean he put
on 50 pounds and like two years is a possible oh Caroline gap tickle face.
I'm not saying anything.
I'm saying when he was 12 tried to
two oh five you're saying when he was eight he fought at one 80 but I know what
the fuck you're saying.
No,
I promised you on it.
I would know what the fuck you're saying.
I get to run into these guys said that he thought he was like 40 years old.
He's lying about his age.
Somebody said that someone knew someone did say Derek.
It's probably Derrick Lewis cause he's so funny.
No,
Derek didn't say that.
Did he hit him?
No.
Derek fighting this weekend.
Who's he fighting?
Something that rushing.
Ken.
He's a bad motherfucker.
I want Derek to win.
It's a good fight.
He's got a real shot at this Dick Francis Black on black crime.
What's up?
Black Panther.
Sick fight.
Derek's a beast,
man.
I like watching him fight.
He was talking about retiring.
Okay.
Yeah.
Mark.
Scene Two Bora.
Yeah.
Why did he want to retire?
I don't know.
Got Damn.
They're still pushing sage Northcutt on us.
Huh?
He's learning and growing.
[inaudible] 10 years old.
Why are you mad about sage?
I'm not mad.
I'm mad at his haircut.
I'm not mad at this age.
I think he's a phenomenal athlete.
Pretty Boys.
No,
dude.
He's a twinkie.
Twinkie is what we call him.
If he was Mexican,
would you be cool with him fighting?
No.
The Mexican crotchety guys forced them on me.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's all right.
All right.
I'm in,
man.
I would love to meet him and see him punk.
I he'd be honest.
I mean,
he's the first fight on the main cards that really forcing them on you.
No,
I get it.
It's like the page van Zandt stuff.
We get it.
They're good looks.
Yeah.
The cuties,
the cuties.
Hey,
all honesty.
It's just kind of listening,
listening,
UNC and punk.
If you fought,
how fast would you beat him?
I'm not even asking if you'd beat him cause I'm not gonna insult you.
How fast would you look at me?
We'll kick his face off.
Well,
it could certainly be quicker than w when I would,
how badly or how quickly I would fail the drug test.
He would never take place.
That drug test would be that they would get with pissing the cup.
They put it in the machine and it would go off like you ever that bugs bunny
cartoon.
When they fucking hit the hammer on the toy and it hits the thing,
slides up and hits the belts and all goes flying over the area.
That's what would happen.
You would take the Piss test.
They go get out.
They'd be like,
he's got the first time everything.
The last time we saw this Peter Bell Park right now and your high rating,
Bro.
He's here right now and say,
Danny gives you like that weird Brock Lesnar exemption.
I'm interested.
No,
I'm saying man.
Yeah,
I'm not interested.
I know he's the guy.
Well,
but what?
Me Too.
I wish him well.
She liked him as a person.
What he's doing,
I would have never recommended,
I would never recommend you climbing Mount Everest without a guide.
I would never recommend you,
uh,
even making it attempt at running a marathon if you've never run a step.
And I know that he's had some training.
I know he's had some training,
but did jump right in to fight in the UFC.
The Megan six kid like Micky gall major leaks or who is a fucking killer.
He's really good on the ground.
Way better than you on the ground.
The idea that someone would think that that's a good idea if I know it's
probably a shit ton of money they gave him and that's all well and good short.
But if you wanted to do it right,
this is what you say.
You say,
listen dude,
we got to get you an amateur fights against a guy who's,
well,
he might not be.
It depends on what he's trying to do,
but if you don't want it to get an amateur fight against someone who is a of
similar skill level and similar experience level,
so you feel what it's like to be going after it.
James,
Jeff Mayweather on Floyd Mayweather's MMA move.
He might actually whip cm punk ass first.
Ooh,
Floyd received punk.
If they do sell the shit out of that fight,
I will be on showtime going good to see you a joke.
This is amazing.
Oh my God,
we got one hell of a fight coming up my heart be still my heart.
They might do that.
They might do,
oh my God,
my heart and you know I'm going to be in my heart.
I can't take it.
My heart is flying on my chest.
If I saw Floyd Mayweather across some cm punk,
I'd be like,
this is not real life.
That's the fighting with,
right?
Well,
listen,
if you may know that Floyd can't fight Conor in an MMA fight,
can let's take that out of the cabin.
But the odds of Connor losing are so astronomically small minus 100,000
favorites.
Like whatever the Fuck Vegas puts on it.
That's cute.
No,
I don't care if it's 10 to one another,
like we don't have odds for this.
We can't.
So you guys can't make money on that's fuck.
It's going to be like 900 to one it's going to be some stuff.
Crazy.
Some buskers Douglas.
Buster Douglas is only like 42 that's crazy.
This is going to be insane if they're smart because Connor is going to kick his
legs out.
He's not even gonna get a chance to come close enough.
He got it.
Everyone kind of is going to kick his fucking legs out.
He doesn't have any chance.
And then if Connor decides to shoot in and clinch,
he's Gunna clench and he's going to ragdoll him.
Well,
he could jump to half guard and do literally name a submission.
Nine that's a slap in Connor snacks minus 900 who the fuck made those?
Oh,
this is nonsense.
that's a joke.
God,
you can take Apple Vida.
Oh my God.
These people are crazy.
My life savings on that.
That's it.
You just money of all time.
They're off by a factor of 10
fucking listen,
if this fight takes place,
Floyd doesn't have a chance about Floyd cm punk though.
I got a fight on what?
He's got a real chance.
Yeah,
Floyd Kaos.
Yeah.
Floyd's got a real chance and less cm punk.
Reuse that in a way,
but also cm punk way bigger.
Okay.
Let's be honest about that.
Cm punk is a guy who was wrestling probably like 190 pounds
cut weight to get to one 70 to fight in the UFC.
Usada though,
son.
Yeah.
Well he's not on anything.
Well,
I don't think he's on AWS.
Pretty Loosey.
Goosy WWE is like in,
right,
but I'm pretty sure he's,
at least according to everybody that I've talked to and everything I've heard
about him,
he's a real straight edge.
No drinking,
no drugs,
no Sarah.
I'm not saying he,
it looks like it.
He looks like now he's clean as they come,
but I think he always was.
I really do.
I don't know.
I don't think he's lying.
Yeah.
Dan said Floyd Mayweather is the fucking greatest boxer maybe of all time.
He's done paper.
He is,
I mean really complements through multiple weight classes.
Undefeated 50 and now I don't care if the last fight was Conor Mcgregor,
he's still 15 that's fucking insane.
Insane.
Yeah,
dude,
he's,
he's on another level of everybody who was on another level.
What this fight is like,
it's like,
it's like you and your buddies at a bar in Floyd walks in and your buddy goes,
you has no background ever.
Maybe did some performance arts in high school and you look at and go,
can you beat up Floyd Mayweather?
And then you guys find out you're gonna get punched in the fucking face very
fast and multiple times.
The question is,
can Floyd fight the same way he fights with big gloves,
with MMA gloves?
The reason why I say this because Floyd's broken his hand multiple times.
He said some serious surgeries on his hands.
Now.
Maybe they've cured it and maybe it's fine,
but we all know that for the longest time Floyd preferred like a puffier glove,
a big money for protection and,
but he hasn't had hand problems in a while.
So maybe he did fix it and his hands looked fucking great against Connor.
How many papers have you used to see cm punk Floyd do and where?
Where do we stop?
This is where you got to come and cut this shit out because I heard,
I heard Morgan Freeman throws a mean psychic.
Do we?
He could sell paper views.
Do we fucking sign him up?
Yeah man.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Like George Clooney.
No,
Larry King.
Larry King to the data,
they're going to die no matter what.
Someone's dying.
So when his die,
once they start swinging we might lose them both.
Good God man,
it's crazy.
It's crazy.
We've been talking about,
it's crazy.
Just odds of carnivorous Floyd in and mixed martial arts match and you know and
else is crazy is Floyd touch it considering it floats,
talking time about MMA fight.
I think he's going to make a half a billion dollars.
He too.
I'd fight anyone on this planet.
If I fight.
Francis could be even the same night for half a billion dollars,
half a billion.
It's really possible.
I mean,
they really might roof rake it in with that fight in the UFC was going to be
willing to do it.
If they met.
Imagine if they made a deal to do too.
He goes,
all right,
I'll tell you one more MMA while do one MMA and one more box and God just,
Ooh,
and you know there's an Esl.
Fuck him up again and you know there's a market for it.
That would be crazy money and the actual admin may heads are turning over in
their graves.
They fucking hate this.
I think you could sell it.
I think if if Connor decided to give like five,
six months for a training camp,
Conor McGregor intox
over stunning $500 million rematches flea with it.
Get your money,
man.
Can't wait.
Get your fucking money.
CanNot wait.
But I would say cm punk because this is what happens that like John's over
Floyd's CNN,
cm punk would have to figure out how to get to take down if they could agree to
me like one 60,
something like that,
maybe cm punk one 16 I tell Duke Roufus take this one out.
And um,
I army crawl over to Floyd cause he kicked him in the face and I just get a hold
of his leg.
It's a complete shit show.
And I fucking just sweep as need that little tiny,
scrawny ankles out and I crawl on top mount and they just stopped the fight.
What if Floyd Mayweather knows karate Wilkie to seriously,
what if we've never seen it before?
He's been hiding it behind closed doors and had hands.
It comes out sideways and starts throwing sidekicks and you're like,
no,
it seemed low.
You imagine if Floyd's starts throwing perfect Moitai leg kicks.
Swat.
What's crazy to me,
my buddy in sixth grade talking about crazy fucking mutans fighter street
fighter.
But let me ask you this,
and all honesty and I are grown men.
If you are a world championship boxer,
you're going to be exposed to a certain around of kickboxers.
Wouldn't you say,
hey man,
show me how to do that.
How do I do that?
It would put part of the leg.
He hit messing around like right here.
Oh Shit,
that hurts.
Oh Shit.
Now show me how to do it.
Show them how to do it on the bag.
I kind of like Floyd Mayweather pickup kicks,
like mastermind.
The way that he could punch the smartest people I've ever been around.
He learns how to dig his body and the things.
He just transferred that to his way.
Brilliant and he would start snapping front kicks on people.
Roundhouse kicks.
Next thing you know you can't get close enough.
You know what that sounds like.
The movie of kickboxer and cm punk storming up in his locker room,
they hit this doosh doosh Floyd Floyd.
Just on the thing.
It came chicken like Pete's brash and cm bunks go.
What the fuck?
No one told me this dude.
Remember Pete Spratt,
Pete Spratt.
It's finished sermon about peat swap.
He's a monster.
For a long,
he would hurt your fucking legs,
man.
Pete sprouts and other dude's like when you watch them kick the pads,
he'd be like,
yikes.
And Guys Ui.
No one I've ever seen kick anything other than a person.
Maybe more terrified than watching Pedro his Oh kick a heavy bag one day.
Well that's fucking Randy couture about it.
Dude.
I'm telling you.
I've seen a lot of powerful guys kick a heavy bag.
There's a,
it sounds different.
Like most like I seen Maurice Smith kick the fucking heavy bag dude.
Mari Smith's,
another one.
Terrifying represented.
Boom,
powerful kicks,
powerful kicks.
He showed me a lot of shit.
He like corrected a lot of things.
I had to like a taekwondo style of throwing my kicks and he was showing me a
bunch of different ways that he delivers things.
Dude.
And he would kick my bag.
It was boom,
fuck your bag up.
Pedro Huizar hits twice as hard.
Is there anyone like that today who kicks us out into Pedro?
His Oh would kick the bag
at Beverly Hills Jujitsu and I'll just sit there like Macaulay Culkin.
Like,
Ooh,
he hits so hard.
Is there anyone like that that kicks today?
Not really.
There's not a lot of heavyweight to kick.
Well,
who kicks like that?
Overeem can kick like that anymore.
He's having a hard time taking the shots that he used to take like,
but when he fought,
um,
uh,
Brett Rogers in strike force,
that was one of the first things he did is crackable Rogers in the leg when he
fought Brock Lesnar.
I mean that's when he was at his best.
It's true.
When the body kick,
Brock Lesnar did,
he's just been through the ringer,
man.
You've got to think I'm still doing it.
Still doing it.
Still like still good luck beating that dude.
He's a nightmare for you.
Look at the division.
He has an amazing ability to re,
oh,
this is horribly.
He kicks his dude.
This poor dude.
Oh no,
he's going to get rid of the bag.
Oh,
don't do it.
Don't do it.
Don't let them do it,
man.
Tell him he breaks his leg.
Oh,
he probably would.
Forrest Griffin broker.
That dude's like,
dude,
watch this.
He just does this.
Just touches it like,
dude,
get a terrible Charley horse from him.
Just touching him.
CV can find a video.
Pedro,
his,
oh,
kicks the heavy bag and it's got to be a good idea.
That's it.
You didn't kick them.
I'll look at Google.
The Randy couture fight.
Randy has a permit.
Dot.
Oh,
here it is.
This guy's going to let him.
He's going to hold the pad and Pedro's Jack wants this shit.
This the fucking power.
Oh Shit.
The guy flew through the air and landed on his back.
Look at this.
Boom.
That guy said,
I'm doing it for the gram son to come on.
He needed view so bad.
He took a leg kick.
I'm telling you,
man,
that I've never seen anybody kick her back harder.
No,
I ain't doing that.
When I saw him thudding into that bag,
I was just imagining my whole body's shutting down like one of those leg kicks.
Your whole body would just go for you.
For you.
I get on a smaller scale,
I guess maybe Barboza by this right now.
Barboza Barboza is a an accumulation guy.
He definitely could knock you out with one shot.
He kicks though.
Yeah,
he's gotten more dexterity for sure.
He could do more different things.
We'll kicks and lighter day.
And his switch kick is just fucking insane.
What Pedro did harder than anybody was like kicks and it was like a terrible,
those are the only guy that's ever stopped someone twice.
And he stopped two different guys.
Monster minutes.
How about,
uh,
I would love to see,
and starting to come out now.
Dos Anjos Woodley,
dude,
that's the fight.
I know what it wants.
A super fight and probably deserved it.
And I was hoping fuck is going on with Woodley and Dana White.
Oh call.
You're calling each other liars and some craziness.
And I thought,
I thought the,
I thought I was talking to woodland,
I thought didn't get the DSI,
which is a good fight.
That's a great fight.
Yeah.
But here's the deal.
Doesn't make sense.
So you know,
numerically rankings,
but fuck rankings these days,
they don't really count who vote.
You look who votes for him.
It doesn't really count.
Belts don't matter.
So it's all about super fights these days,
which is unfortunate for Woodley though.
That's why once the super,
well why wouldn't
you?
You'd have to be crazy to not,
I'll tell you make money.
That's where he met.
My guys won it and that's a big fight.
You have Nate Diaz finding them.
And here's the thing,
both guys,
whether it's Nate Diaz or dos Anjos are going to provide the kind of fight that
I think Tyron needs because I think Tyron fought to super difficult guys,
fought Damien Maia,
which you cannot take to the ground.
And then he fought Wonderboy Thompson who's super awkward to fights where there
wasn't the kind of action that everybody wanted.
But see really the only way to successfully fight Wonderboy.
Yeah you can,
but you're looking at Woodley gets a bad rap and he look at his track record.
You know the how many times he fought last year in defend the title and his
finishes and the quickest knocked out in the,
in the division.
He's a monster.
But he gets this hate cause you're only as good as your last fight.
So you have the Maya fight,
which house?
Unified my iron man and then again any his shoulder early in the fight,
but I agreed a dos Anjos ink and then he's going to bring it,
which is exactly what Woodley needs.
Hundred Percent Dose Angeles is a dangerous fight for and if I'm literally,
I take that fight because you need it.
If you don't fight you out of the public eye,
like especially the fight fans,
you can be in all the movies you want.
You can do that.
TMZ show that's not moving the needle.
Then you got to fight.
But for dos Anjos is a super dangerous fight because he's got to get inside that
danger zone.
We're tiring could put anybody to sleep.
You've got to think.
Tyron is the only guy who taught me Matt Brown beat the shit out of Wonderboy.
But that was early in wonder boys career and also the word was that Wonderboy
came into that fight over train.
It was working on his wrestling,
working on his take down defense.
He was flat coming to the fight and Matt Brown,
it's just a fucking animal.
Right.
Other than that,
no one else has really hurt him except for Tyron and in both of those fights,
you got to think wonder boys,
the big time striker and one of the best kick boxers to ever fight in MMA,
especially like American karate styles and phenomenal,
there's are now might be the best,
but yeah,
phenomenal.
Top of the food chain,
top three would the hurts him blast him twice.
Both fights.
Both fights Woodley's the one who almost wins by stoppage.
You've got to respect that.
That's incredible that he was able to catch him.
It's incredible that he has the kind of power that even the fourth round,
he could still put a fucking hurting on him and almost put them away while he's
a monster.
And also remember Wonderboy beat ready Robert Whitaker,
right?
Whitaker's last laws [inaudible] but that was also Whitaker at one 70 he was
having a really odd to say that.
That's still fucking impressive.
I think that was what prompted him to move up or one of the things,
one of them,
one I was like,
Eh,
maybe not,
but either way for for I think dos Anjos he be here.
I remembered though Sandoz striking with,
um,
out there at a king's with reducing and those boys,
uh,
Hatfield Co Codero he,
I'm a fucking and strike at 70.
He's a nightmare.
And also he can grapple man.
Yes,
very dangerous.
He's dangerous to play with them.
You know what he did with Neil?
Maggie too.
It's like Jesus Christ.
It's just choose him up.
Just chewed him up,
man.
He's a fucking animal.
Take good fight for Woodley.
I want to get the Diaz fight for him personally and get paid and it's a great
matchup for him,
but that they'll say,
Angeles fights a motherfucker.
Here's what I think.
I think Woodley in any other situation other than that,
that lineup of Damien Maia and two Wonderboy fights.
Take those fights out of the equation.
You got Robbie Lawler who he starches by knockout,
get Josh Koscheck who he puts into another dimension.
You have all these people,
he's smashing the j here on fight.
I mean you're looking at a smasher,
he smashes people.
So you give him a couple other fights of people that are forced to stand with
them.
I know people that are in that division though.
If there was a different lineup of contenders,
he would have gone through these fights and if he had emerged victorious like he
did,
his face is an amazing face of the UFC.
Yeah.
Amazing results.
Right.
And he's great on TV.
He's a great talker.
He's articulate.
He creates story about his Momma House.
Yeah.
And he's very even,
you know what I'm saying?
Like he doesn't have like crazy ups and downs when we've talked.
It's very easy to listen to.
I mean he's got a tremendous belief in himself,
but every champion does.
They have to.
So all he needed was the right kind of match.
Those three fights,
kind of fuck them of these fights were talking about,
are that right?
Kind of match up.
They're both the right kind of match up.
Nate Diaz is the right kind of match up.
Nate is going to fucking bring in.
That's going to be a crazy fight.
And for sure dos Anjos is the crazy matchup at one 70 and we,
when you remember what dos Anjos did to Nate at one 55 you gotta go,
you gotta give the shot to dos.
Anjos have to switch.
You have to dose Anjos just his last big Windman and less.
He creates a step aside for a little peace.
Who maybe need creases,
step aside and fools.
And for Nate,
man,
I know you guys got got to get that money.
Just give me a days.
God does it back.
Just give me 50 but 150 give me 100100150 150 to do nothing.
But did you ever shot at Vince?
He thinks Woodley's making mistake.
You Know Rashad had the same problem where he was arguing with Dane and not
focusing on his career shot.
It goes,
it'll fuck you up when you put all this energy and Dana and the business size
and you're not taking care of the fight business dot five business.
I don't understand.
So I don't want to judge,
but I don't,
you know,
you don't want to get involved with that because you're not going to in less and
less.
And I say this and it's frustrating,
but unless you're a Conor McGregor type of drawl and there's not a lot you can
read,
there's not a lot to argue with.
Man is always going to come out on top and,
and,
and um,
it's not a knock on Dana.
If I'm Dana,
I don't know if I run it any other way.
Right.
It's like my shoulder of the highway,
my man.
Like,
what are you going to do?
That's the way you run a big giant ass business like that.
I get it.
You're a dictator.
There's mean,
maybe there's another way to do it,
but it hasn't been done before.
It's possible.
I'm just think I don't have any experience in it how I want to talk about shit.
I don't have any experience and I let,
I know that Shit I don't know about.
I know there's a lot of career off of nightmares scenarios that they've
encountered on both sides,
you know?
But I think that I just would never want to have arguments with the fighters.
I feel like,
especially like calling me to the liars and shit,
it just seems crazy weird
people.
I'd be like,
look,
it doesn't
help anyone because if you're dany go,
he's a,
he's a fucking liar to know what he's talking about.
He's a born fighter.
He makes you money,
you're diminishing your product.
And if your Woodlin go,
you're a fucking liar.
You told me I was fit and ideas,
but that's now Dana and goes,
all right,
well now I don't wanna look like a complete Dick and liar,
so I'm not giving you that fight.
I said,
I didn't want to do it.
Maybe I told you behind closed doors,
we're going to do it.
You just call me out in public now.
Well now I can't go back on my word and I can that fight.
They probably brought it up to him because that's what they're saying.
He said,
I said a lawyer brought it up.
Oh,
he said a UFC lawyer who is very invested in us.
He makes a lot of matches to the law.
A lot of calls,
if the name slips my mind right now,
a lawyer when the UFC who works with the UFC actually tried making the fight
happened.
That's weird that you say that because he said that the lawyers contacted Tyron
and tell them to stop saying that.
Well,
I'm sure after he made it,
gave him the offer and Dana goes,
what the fuck?
Take that on.
I don't know how that works.
Meaning either,
I don't know.
But the point was on your show,
did he talk about it at all?
No,
it hadn't been.
I don't think it had been brought up then.
You know,
he had just gone through,
so shoulder surgery,
uh,
he just had his labor.
I'm fixed,
which is an entity thing like,
hey man,
how long does that take to fix?
You've got to make sure that shit gets fixed.
Right?
It's due in July.
Yeah.
I mean,
hopefully it'll be done right,
but that's four or five months.
It's touch and go with shoulder injuries.
Really don't know why,
especially his style.
That shoulder needs to be 100% he's a fucking exploder correct.
Uh,
loads on that.
Jay here on fight when he storms forward and fucking throws that shine overhand,
right?
Like whoa,
that's a fucking explosion.
And now,
yeah,
because they were going to try and make them come back quicker because they're
trying to fill that UFC two 22 and then you've got cars,
you've got frank or Tager Frankie,
yeah,
in Ortega.
Right.
And then cyborg versus a girl.
You've never heard of one thing though.
He's like super proactive on his recovery.
He's talking about PRP and stem cells and all Sherman complete professional
Woodley is as fresh as they get as they get.
And I also think he's probably going to be smart about it if it's not a hundred
percent you know,
so maybe he's planning for it to be 100% and maybe there are a few months out.
If it's not,
they can always readjust.
But he also has other forts in the fire.
He goes,
you know,
I get the UFC tonight Gig,
I get this TMZ sports show so you can force my hand.
But I got these other gigs over here too,
which is smart.
He's smart.
And he's also got his a youtube thing that he does,
you know,
champ life.
He does his own [inaudible] embedded.
Yup.
He's does his own done.
What is it?
Is it called champ life?
I think it's called champ life.
Find out what it is.
I'm pretty sure Tyron Woodley show is called smart.
You gotta you gotta you gotta do your thing.
Very smart.
You got to,
he means diversifying his output.
It's very smart.
Well,
I think a lot of learning from you,
a lot of guys are learning from you.
I mean,
they've got to realize that you're funny.
Get you better be funny to champ life.
That's it.
The Champ Lifetime Woodley.
Um,
but there's,
I think it's smart,
you know,
to try to make some sort of a transition.
What separates you from a lot of these guys is you're very funny.
And that's a,
you either are or you aren't.
I Dunno if Tyron is that funny,
but he's definitely a bad motherfucker and I,
I want to see what he's up to.
I think that's interesting.
And I think that these kinds of shows,
look,
would you want to watch some kid electrified dead rats or do you want to watch
how the baddest motherfucker said that gray red ones 17th in the world.
That's why we're brothers lives his life.
Don't you want to watch that guy train?
He's electrocuting dead rats after retirement.
I ended,
check this out though.
Tyron Woodley's fucking everybody up on the planet.
It's dudes.
I mean,
when you want to watch that,
that to me is the guy.
It's a fine line though.
And I like what the woodleigh's doing,
stuff like that.
And you have to have almost another team control it.
You know,
with Frankie,
Frankie has the UFC gym,
he has all these other business endeavors because I don't deal with it all.
I have a TV deals.
It,
I focused on fighting cause for Woodley's very hands on.
That's what made them world champion.
And if you're not focused on things,
and I said this is the cowboy.
I said,
what do you think?
Uh,
you know Dan till was doing,
when you're on these movie sets,
man,
he's kicking bags.
He's think about beating you so you gotta be very,
it's a fine line.
It's a super fine line and you know,
you don't see the NFL athletes with NBA athletes trying all these other avenues
because they're making bank so they don't have to do it.
Things distracting.
Anything that you have to do is taken away from your art.
And if you,
if you've ever been on a movie set before,
have you ever done a movie?
I've been on set,
yes.
The shows that you counted together.
It's a lot of fucking work,
man.
It takes a long rollout of those.
So it was even more work.
But yeah,
when you're on set it's hurry up and wait.
You're not doing anything else.
If you are a guy who has to be in FFA and shape for a world title fight world
class fight like that,
like anybody trying to do a movie before,
like a big fight like man,
you better spend a lot of time looking at Rhonda.
She could go back to,
but you look at Rhonda,
it's just you have the wrong people in here know you can do this.
You can do this and now WME controls UFC and we'll put you in this movie.
I put you in this movie.
God,
I don't know man.
I got to strike while the irons hot.
And what's really interesting man,
is how many times that story repeats itself over and over again.
I mean,
that's the theme in rocky four rocky fights clubber Lang.
He's getting all soft and shit and he's in movies and shit.
He's in movies.
We'll haul Kogan remember that?
Yeah,
I mean all this crazy shit.
Was it a movie with hogoken or is it TV show?
It was an exhibition
to move around and then walks all serious coke.
He's like,
wrestlers are no joke,
Matt wrestlers like you could say all you want,
that wrestling is fake.
I'm ended WWE now,
the fucking athleticism those guys have and the toughness to show slam each
other around like that.
And they were like 300 nights a year,
man.
It's a monster.
It's a monster uncle.
He's a buddy.
He throws the loaded and the fucking crowd.
Jack is so crowd now.
Who's catching Stallone?
Is it a team of stuntmen you think?
Yeah,
for sure.
It must have practices that it looks like a dental that that's not a real
person.
That looks like a fake person,
isn't it?
I thought,
but it has to be and there's no way they could have pulled that off.
You don't think so?
No,
I don't think so,
man.
You look at the body,
that Shit's real.
I don't know fellas.
That's not rubbery enough.
I feel like his legs adjust in mid air,
man.
He,
you can tell the difference between someone's legs adjusting and they're not
adjusting.
Yeah,
you might be right.
I had a buddy do a move as stone cold stone cold with rocky and they sits
Sylvester Stallone will tell real fight stories from his movies,
like their actual fights.
But I remember when I was in the of Hulk Hogan,
I'm married through this left and I saw the core.
Maya was like,
not today.
Yeah.
Why aren't you so like in that fight world.
And he'll talk about his old fight.
Seems like they were actual fights or fun or is he really think that they
fought?
Here's the thing.
The guy gets old enough and they get famous for saying crazy shit.
That's definitely him.
He had just whips forward.
When he throws him in,
he pulls his head back away from the ground power.
How close up,
dude?
I ran into Hulk Hogan once.
I met hall cocaine when I did a the UFC.
I had an interview on once and it was one of the fondest fucking interviews.
My,
first of all,
I couldn't believe I'm sitting there talking to Hulk Hogan,
but he's pumping up wrestling and so I got fucked,
super pumped up about it.
I got jazzed up,
was mugging for the camera.
It was so stupid,
but it was one of the funnest times I've ever had ever enough.
Show me,
Oh,
we'll get you,
man.
Huge personality.
How are you?
It doesn't get any better than this brother.
These guys are going to war out here.
It's unbelievable that you've made,
it's an intimate fights before you a you a UFC fan.
I'm a huge fan.
My brother.
Now,
I understand that you have recently announced a partnership with TNA wrestling
and his prison.
If he takes the course,
we're going to see some Hulkamania.
No.
Is this the same organization that Billy Corgan owns?
Does even,
which one does he own?
I'm pretty sure he owns TM.
I'm pretty sure he bought this one.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure you list that podcast.
You'll do that one.
How cool is Billy Corgan?
Why was it hard to be friends with them?
He just decides to buy it for wrestling.
He knows his shit though.
As far as wrestling goes.
I know,
but how funny it is when you hear him talk and he's like,
yeah,
everybody wants me to be all emo,
but yeah,
no,
I love it.
Then I used to hate him.
Go ahead.
He bought the national wrestling alliance Nwa,
Nwa.
That's TNA and then Nwa and hulk.
He used to be part of Nwa to right Nwa.
Nwa was ric Flair,
right?
Wasn't it ric flair?
What's that?
Nwa was ric flair and that they want him to go Debbie.
Debbie.
That's right.
Woo.
Do I have ric flair tee shirts now?
Should you should ric flair is a bad motherfucker.
I'm trying to get him on my show.
Yeah,
he should have him on here.
I would love to have on here,
Rick,
if you're out,
you're out there sir.
Open invitation dude.
But when I'm in the rest of you seen that video of the football players in the
green room?
Yes.
Like corrals repeating it and then in between Rick,
the nature boy flare,
sang it back.
No,
I haven't seen that.
Yeah,
I just need help.
Please bring that up to see if you find it.
It's a,
I forget the team that was doing it,
but they were yelling out his slogan and in between limousine ride in Tuxedo,
fine.
I'm having a hard time keeping these gators down.
Okay,
here it is.
Here it is.
It you give it to me from the beginning.
Whoa,
whoa.
No.
They did
this and then they spliced it in with ric flair.
See if you can find that.
They'd Zem say in one line and then Rick flair saying the second line and then
going back to them.
Pull this out again.
Outcomes down.
Yeah,
dude,
it's fucking amazing.
I don't think that's it.
See you.
You get,
there's a video out there.
Someone has it,
dude.
I've never been one.
Send it to Jamie on Twitter.
I've never been more moved by documentary then I'll watch it.
This is it.
Hello?
I mean
someone like a catchphrase,
like someone's saying something that's just,
that just gives you goosebumps and makes you fire it up and make you start
fucking clapping due to this day.
If you say ric flair on stage and hold the microphone out,
the whole audience will go,
Ooh.
Even Australia Wall Matthews was like balls deep with a guy or Gal.
Join his eyes out.
You heard woo.
Yeah,
Dude.
Everybody all over the world.
All over the world.
But it's like an amazing,
weird occurrence that happens every now and then.
We're a guy just nails something and becomes a part of pop culture forever.
But think about it,
Floyd Connor,
they're all ripping off from him.
That's where they got it.
Remember he was way before all of that.
Well,
it's a mom and I'll leave it before him though.
Muhammad Ali was talking shit like that in the 1960 [inaudible] not like that
though.
Right.
Not like posting about what his riches and like,
you know what I'm saying?
Not to that level.
My God,
that level dude,
Mohammed Ali would write poems.
I know poems,
but not about money and splurging and limousines and bitches and alligators.
Maybe not about bitches.
Now 80 was different though.
Huey talked about Grady was how he's finished,
been around,
stuff like that.
I've seen that.
I'm saying as far as like boasting and in that almost that,
that low level,
um,
where were rags to riches,
you know what I'm saying?
Like maybe he did,
I don't know,
but I know he would be a little people to no end.
He said about Jimmy Tarella said,
Jimmy trail,
I have a dreams.
He beats me better.
Wake up and apologize.
And he was,
he would say,
shit,
he's a parole.
Who Fuck you said that whoever is fine.
I thought it was the Frasier we said for even dreams about being right.
I don't think it was,
but I mean there were so many of those fucking interviews where he talks so much
crazy shit talk shit.
But I'm trying to give me something,
see mark falling five rounds,
but if you talk about me,
I would cut it three.
I'll never find another fellow stuff up.
Not even that big of embarrassed of this stuff.
Is he on x night?
Well,
after I eat now late,
this hinder coop,
I want that bear and what's going on here and bad.
What's going to happen?
He might be great,
but he'll fall in eight.
I'm the prettiest fight in the ring the day.
That's my label.
He was a smart guy,
man.
He talked crazy shit.
I'm too fast.
But it was always about his skills,
so it wasn't like that.
This much money.
I have a limo,
I have a Rolex.
We're like Floyd and like Rick bring that to another level.
That's true.
Right.
He took the,
I'm a rich guy thing to a new level and bragged about his riches.
He cause he was a heel,
so he's like,
I got money,
I got bitches,
I got daters for coats.
What's up?
I'm having a hard time holding these alligators down
that again
when last year,
sunglasses,
liquor,
there's bars from one side of this world or the other.
Then you made,
you're talking to the Rolex.
That is the best line of all time.
I'm just happy.
That's a real person.
Me Too.
You know what I mean?
That's like every now and then someone creates a character,
right?
They nail something,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's just when,
when a guy can do that and it gets to everybody.
You know how it's so hard these days to be original and like that because
there's been so many great fingers before safepoint point give these lines like
what's,
when's the last time you heard someone come up with a new quote that someone's
like inspired by like it's all old.
You know what the worst thing is when someone tries a quote but it don't work?
There's nothing more painful.
Those.
Nothing more painful.
But I thought about the,
there's really,
you're not going to come up with some new quotes that we haven't heard
before.
It's,
it's all too,
it's been done before,
man.
Yeah.
There's some wacky ones out there though.
Some people try super hard for especially hot girls with Instagram.
Like don't fuck with Einstein's quote and post her ass.
How dare you can move from that house here.
You [inaudible] triangle do,
did you see Elon Musk?
Where,
where do you have you seen this?
We're Trump goes thank god to space x.
Stuff like that.
Shows you how basically something about Americans and Eli Musk goes,
I'm from South America.
Dumb Ass South Africa.
That's right.
Yeah.
It's holiday comma.
Dumb ass.
That's hilarious.
Hilarious.
It's false.
Is that fake?
Nope.
Says it was false,
but damn,
that's
my friend sent that to Methodist.
Hilarious.
Cause I'm like,
yeah,
well how do you not love a guy who shoots a fucking car in the space and then
put,
we'd was built by humans.
Let him do whatever he wants.
Hey man,
if I said to you,
hey,
Brendan,
um,
uh,
let's go to the White House and asked him if we could shoot a car in a space.
You're like,
what the fuck is wrong with you man?
I'm going to go there.
I'm going to just tell him I got this idea.
I've got like a tube and a some gun powder.
I'm going to light the bottom part on fire,
right?
Tesla never done it before,
but I'm pretty sure I could shoot a car in space.
I'm going to have a mannequin APPA car.
Well,
where's it going to go?
It's just going to float around in space.
Try to get to Mars.
We're didn't overshoot.
Done what?
This is one of the things that who was,
who was saying this?
Oh,
Dunkin were like,
what if I'm the spaceship shot this car in this space and this car hits and
asteroids.
It sends it hurling towards her.
It's just like a bomb changes the direction of this asteroid because it's one of
the things they've always said,
like if an asteroid is coming our way,
they would shoot something at it.
It would bounce it out of the way,
like Armageddon and that would save us the Armageddon.
Bruce Willis did it.
Yeah.
Um,
but what if it bounced towards us?
What is this asshole shooting his fucking car with David Bowie on the stereo and
this fucking clips,
this asteroid,
it goes to men's right to us.
Boom.
Elon Musk.
Biggest stick of all time then.
Or what if we shoot that car in the space and it hits an alien spaceship that's
coming here to give us wisdom just completely through the windshield.
That's a negative way.
It's just the flat Earth Guy.
Oh,
that guy is crazy.
He's only raised $110 dumb cause you ain't not mass.
Hold on.
It's only $110 at a $10,000 goal.
Listening flat.
Earthers you need to put your money where your mouth is.
I'm starting to believe that you don't really believe in this cause.
Yeah,
send my boy Michael Hughes.
$10,000 and you get your liver spotted hands off.
My mother,
he's had a couple of shots at it.
He bailed on the first shot.
Fails,
right?
I don't think he's actually does.
He launched himself in this space yet.
I think they got the late a few times.
The first time he's going to do it that the government got involved and I was
like,
yeah,
you can't do that.
You know that is such a crazy move to make your own rocket doesn't fucking,
he has $10,000.
If Eddie,
you think there's flat fucking give this guy some money.
But what about that Bob character isn't eve super wealthy,
does a mezzanine funding single and forever cause he's been too busy with flat
earth theory.
Listen man,
once he understands the fucking real true image of the earth and then you have a
wall that surrounds the outer realm of the earth and everybody thinks is worth
is round,
you got some shit to tell the people.
It's more important than your rap song.
You made things,
Ron,
you've got to get people.
Whoa,
look,
you're the guy from blink lay too.
When it's moved on,
this noise moved on.
Y'All got to take this flat earth shit to the next level.
Uh,
fuck the flat versus round argument.
Let's talk more about the simulation and who's programming it is.
That's how both sides get benefit.
If it's round or flat,
oh my God.
[inaudible] going through some shit.
Fuck this flatter stuff.
What else can we talk?
Well,
here's the thing,
and this is something really important for anybody who's listening to this.
You got to not hang yourself on your ideas.
I've done it.
I did in the past.
When you do that,
you're not really paying attention.
You're only looking for things that support your idea.
It's called confirmation bias.
Everybody,
if everybody is susceptible to it,
me included,
have,
I've done it a hundred times to myself and the task,
but once you realize what it is,
if you keep doing the same goddamn thing,
then you're being stupid.
So once you know what it is and you know it's possible,
we'll do,
let's just look at this.
Look at all the overwhelming amount of evidence from super geniuses that say
it's round just you got to walk away.
It's,
it's,
it hurts you.
It hurts your view of the world to believe that because you can't believe it if
you're really paying attention.
So if you believe that what you're saying is you have a very limited box in
which you're willing to operate in.
He not willing to accept anything outside of what you've already got has a
preconceived idea and you're ignoring massive amounts of data that points to the
fact that you're wrong.
So by doing that,
you limit your own view of yourself,
you,
you become you.
You don't trust in the way you view things anymore.
You're boxed in.
It's very dangerous to be committed to something you know is not true.
It also shows the level of diligence too because when you got these geniuses who
spent their entire lives doing in this stuff and astrophysics,
you're telling me that they're a part of this scheme to and they believe that
this is 100% of the problem.
100% it's adopting an idea too soon.
That's 100% of the idea because once you,
once you adopt that idea and then you hang onto it,
now you're fucked.
Like big foot mat.
Bigfoot was a big one for me.
I was,
I was convinced it was real with you.
How long ago with this?
Couple of weeks ago when I
not what I know to you.
Um,
yeah man.
When I did this TV show,
that's when I totally let it go.
I'd kind of let it go before then,
but Dunkin and I actually went to the Pacific northwest and we went to hang out
with like real big foot experts.
It was searching for bigfoot all the time.
When you say real big foot at x,
which you mean con artist?
No,
it's not that dumb ass.
The way I described it as unfuckable white dudes who have nothing do,
there's just,
they're just a bunch of fellows.
We decided a car self,
a rap band.
We're going to call ourselves a Ufw d fuckable white dude.
You didn't find him out there in the Pacific fat camp spots.
A lot of spent shells and beer cans laying around.
You're better than that Joe.
No,
this is what I found out.
People want to believe in things and once you want to believe in something
instead of looking at it objectively and going,
wow,
I'm not sure you like automatically go towards any information that would point
to the fact that the thing is real,
not to the whole body of information.
Look well how crazy these people when you meet the people that believe in
bigfoot,
the blends that have seen it,
the ones that had claimed a scene,
it almost all of them were clearly lying in a little like out of it,
but it was one lane.
Bactrim maybe.
Yeah,
but just some people are just liars.
They can't help it.
They make stories up to make themselves feel better.
Like they just crazy and you can't really say it to their face cause you don't
really know.
But sometimes it just gets ridiculous.
And this one lady was one of the only ones that didn't seem like that.
This one lady was telling me a story about how she was going through the woods
and she saw some big thing that was standing up and it was like seven feet tall
and it was moving through the woods and uh,
she saw this thing and she was like,
oh my God,
it's an ape.
And then she realized it was big foot and she saw it for a few steps and then it
was gone.
At the time I was fascinated at the time I was like,
maybe she really did see it,
but now I know for a fact,
an absolute fact that where she lived,
there's a lot of black bears and black bears will often walk on their hind legs.
They'll walk like bigfoot.
They really do.
There's many,
many,
many videos.
I've seen it with my own two eyes.
I saw a bear walked for several steps,
like six,
seven,
maybe even 10 steps on its hind legs roaring at another bear.
And they were going to fight with each other and they fought with Joe standing
up.
They went after each other.
Nope.
But dude,
he walked towards him like that.
Look at that.
That does look like they do that.
So that bear,
this is a bear that had injured pause and sometimes they'll get their pod bid
off in a fight,
take Duke it out with each other or maybe they get caught in a trap.
You know,
some fucking assholes.
It set traps out there for the foolish to walk like that.
They buy back their own foot off to get out of a trap then that's real man.
They,
they,
they get wolves that way.
They catch them and traps [inaudible] traps are scary shit.
But these animals,
you know when they get a hurt paw they'll walk on their back legs like big foot.
So she probably saw some shit moving through the woods.
Like Shit.
Yeah Dude,
they just stand there.
That's terrifying.
I know.
And they can walk like that.
That's terrifying.
But it's clearly not a fucking big,
you moron.
No,
no,
no.
See you say that.
But Dude,
I'm telling you when you're in the Pacific northwest,
you cannot see 15 yards in front of you.
Duncan and I were talking it,
cause you know we had a hang out up there and go wander into the woods where
like if there was something right there,
like five trees away and then it moved into the back,
how long would it take for disappeared through steps.
Three steps.
It's so dance dude.
It's like a qtip box,
you know,
and you get cute tips out of a box.
So many of them,
this is no gaps in between these trees.
Have you been to the Pacific northwest?
Like the rain forest?
I've ever been in there.
I mean I,
he drunk drove through it.
It's amazing.
And here's the other thing about it.
It's all pine needles so that you don't even make any noise.
But I would see a standing figure like that in,
in my educated pray.
I go,
oh,
that's a fucking giant bear.
No,
because you'd be looking at a hill like a hundred yards away.
And he would see this thing walked through the trees standing up and he'd be
like,
what in the fuck was that?
And then it's gone.
So then your imagination starts running wild.
And your imagination starts filling in the blanks.
I don't think it's a coincidence.
The higher not for sure your high,
well then I'd probably think you're going to Seattle,
man.
Okay,
then why would you not be high,
but you're eating mushrooms.
Oh,
spirit,
your highest fuck all on shrooms.
Everybody up there,
son shrimps,
and that's a walking Brown Unicorn.
You're walking down this road in the forest and you see something that's in the
woods and you see it briefly a hundred yards away for three or four steps.
Your brain starts filling in the blanks and you get excited.
You saw fucking big foot and I will go to my grave knowing what I saw that day.
And everybody wants to be special,
so everybody wants to pretend they saw a giant monkey in the woods,
but when you really talk to them,
that was the only lady I knew that wasn't lying to me.
She saw something she has.
She thought it was big for she was standing.
If I had a guest,
if I had some money to bet,
I would bet almost 100% what she saw was a bear.
You did the show and have to come and back.
When that show you like,
you know what big bullshit and it's the same feeling.
I got talking to everybody.
Psychic readers,
same feeling.
I got talking to Ufo experts.
Same feeling.
I got to,
everybody wants to believe.
Everybody wants to be a I can fucks with the UFO.
Makes sense to me.
There's so many kind of sure you x factors there.
I can buy a u f so it could be real.
It could be real big flood.
Come on.
Here's the thing about big foot.
The reason why it's so attractive is because it used to be a real animal.
100% it was a thing called gigantic [inaudible] shit up.
They didn't know about gigantic [inaudible] until I believe it was the 1920s
they found a tooth of this primate in an apothecary shop in China and they're
like,
what the fuck is this selling it?
Yeah.
There were selling it and someone found another tooth and they said,
oh,
there's another,
and the primatologist who check it out there.
That was a real animal cod tog
eight foot tall,
gigantic orangutan.
Looking thing.
It's like a human cause then they rang a tank family.
No,
no,
no dude,
it doesn't,
well big foot's supposed to look like that.
It's supposed to look like,
yeah,
it's not supposed to be like a human.
Well I thought it was like a hero.
There's a photo of a man standing next to a proportionate man.
The average size man standing next to which I can't go his statue.
See if you could find that in there.
I know it's pick up this.
Yeah,
that's it.
That was how big it was.
So that was a real animal.
100% now they're not 100% sure that it walked on two legs,
but they're pretty sure.
And the reason why is the shape of the teeth,
that animals that walk on their hind legs,
animals that walk upright have a different shape to their jaw.
So that's what they found.
It looks like they found a job bone and they found some teeth and they found it
like all on the same site and then they realize that they're dealing with a
totally different animal that he was around.
How long ago?
10,000 years ago.
So this thing existed somewhere in the neighborhood of,
I think that's right.
Wait a minute,
that might be wrong.
I think I'm thinking of the Flores man was the hobbit man,
the little three foot tall dude.
That dude was like 10 14,000 years ago.
That was really soon.
Like really recently.
Definitely lived alongside people that this might be 100,000.
What makes it attractive though is where that thing lived is exactly where all
the animals cam across the Bering land bridge that connected Asia to North
America.
So this Bering land bridge was where they think everything came across.
Short face bear.
Even people that like,
one of the things about native Americans,
it's a funny thing how they found this out.
They found this out through a crazy Mormons who wanted to prove that all of the
native Americans were actually lost tribe of Israel because that was what
Mormons a crazy brother.
At least they got some right though.
So they've got one thing,
right?
Yes,
baby.
If that part of the rolling,
that's why nobody's fighting over there and chill.
So,
so,
um,
so this guy who's like some rich Mormon guy spends a shit ton of money.
It turns out he gets the DNA tests and they're all from Siberia.
Really?
Yup.
Yeah.
They came down from Siberia.
That's why,
you know,
they look different as they go through the different climates.
You know,
if you look at like,
um,
Inuits in like Alaska and then that area,
they look super similar to Siberians man Siberians have that strong features,
paints the hand cheek Mongol like,
uh,
like,
like Gingiss con looking face like powerful people do.
That's what they look.
They're all from Siberia to there from Siberia.
And so that as they came down and got deeper than in North America,
then you got all sorts of different influences,
shit,
different kinds of people.
But they look different and they start looking more and more Mexicans.
When you get down to the Mayans,
the Mayans are very Mexican as texts.
It's all Mexican.
And then they've got people coming in from Spain and teaching them Spanish.
But you've got to realize these people started off essentially native Americans
before the Spanish arrived.
Yeah.
It's really interesting,
Scott.
Dude,
it's super interesting.
Stomach found that shit.
So Mormon found that shit by trying to prove that his,
his shit was right.
But the problem is,
fuck all this time,
I'll just wrap it up here.
All this time is when that animal existed.
So this animal was a real animal during this time.
So during the time that all these animals were coming across the Bering land
bridge,
it's highly likely that there might've been one of those fucking things that
came over to,
and then people started to share stories and became this folks probably dead.
Now it's dead in Asia,
but the native Americans have a bunch of different names for it.
One of the things that's interesting about the Sasquatch and native American
culture,
I think they have 40 different names for it.
Too much.
Well,
I think it existed.
I think something like that existed,
or it could have been the same thing about this lady.
She sees a bear walking on two legs,
a story to,
you know,
they tell a tale and they also were smoking a lot of shit and he and a lot of
shrooms dance,
right dog.
A lot of that goes a lot of that.
San Pedro,
cactus Iowasca and shit.
I see a cat.
I think it's pretty clear bump,
bump,
bump drums and shit in front of the fire on Payoti
execute people with knives and shit.
Drinking.
There's a lot,
Jamie.
All the different names for bigfoot.
Come on.
That's crazy buddy.
That different native American big foot name.
But are these like those gender pronouns or people are just waking him up?
Yeah,
you can.
The meeting over here isn't always just like big one big man with a little hat.
Oh,
that's my boy.
Harry Savage.
Autumn man.
Dangerous Bushmen.
Dangerous being a trickster.
Yeah,
a lot of different,
yeah.
See the cannibal like that.
A lot of that can be attributed to a lack of understanding of what really is out
there.
They don't have an accurate account of all the different animals and he knows a
bunch of them that can kill them.
Yeah,
we do.
We would find it by now.
The government would find it if they're,
the shit was out there,
so you know,
find it.
That other trinity would find it.
Tim Kennedy would find it.
If you hear about Kim Hayes new show,
I don't mean to interrupt you.
Hurting yourself for Hitler.
Hit hard to kill.
They put him in certain situations.
See if he gets out of it.
What are,
boy Abra is telling me about this today.
It's on discovery history.
They doing that because Tim Kennedy,
you can't kill him.
He's captain America.
They're like put him in a burning planning yet.
Like third degree burns.
He makes it out alive.
They put them in the avalanche.
He gets out alive.
Dude,
they shouldn't do this
dude too.
He's such a monster.
It's a fucking animal.
But I know he's the best human.
I tell him for a TV show now that you can't kill him.
You literally can't kill me.
He's a person.
Nah,
we're Merrill was waiting there with a hammer.
He's got a real problem on his hands.
If you all,
it's waiting there with EPO and a hammer.
He's in trouble.
Yup.
Interesting.
Crazy show though,
right?
Yeah.
That's a crazy idea.
He's another guy who they put him on anything.
I'm interested in him on anything.
I said.
Fascinating Guy,
great guy.
He's a guy who's parlayed his career after fighting something great.
Well,
he is a professional bad motherfucker.
I mean that's literally who he is,
but he's
a smart guy.
He's educated,
but he's a bad motherfucker.
He's got good advice for people.
Just the baddest motherfucker and just like it and he's nice.
Dude.
Don't die.
Tim Kennedy,
please,
please.
Dot.
No,
I heard that shot for TV.
I go,
what if he dies?
Not for TV.
Tim,
can I get those ratings on?
Yeah.
I just,
again,
when you want to just see that guy hanging around all day,
well,
I mean if you,
do people really want to go see the Kardashians house and look at my shoes.
Oh my God.
Super Cute.
They really want to see that.
Or do they want to see Tim Kennedy at the range Talkin Shit.
Practicing killing terrorists.
Oh,
see both doable.
I want,
I don't want to see the other one.
You want to see the other one will not.
I don't care what they said,
but I,
I'd like to see Tim Kitty in the Kardashians House.
Teach them how to fight.
Ooh,
okay.
I see what it makes it.
You know what I'm saying?
Him and Kanye.
Do you think they would see Iti?
Yeah,
I do.
Caitlin Jenner.
Jim Kennedy is like the Anti Conway.
I bet he would be interesting with Kaitlin.
I bet he'd be interesting.
He's very open minded guy.
I mean he doesn't give a fuck what you do.
Just don't get in the way of the military.
I'm thinking this way,
not,
it's not like looking and tell people how to live their life.
Damn right.
He has a show should have a show.
Well,
I think there's a lot,
there's a lot of missed opportunities that a lot of these guys have,
but they're what they are as unique individuals.
It's like there's people that are good at promoting themselves and then there's
people that just don't,
they don't have that pressure in the fighters.
Like Steve Bay.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
I feel like Steve Bay is a can't lose scenario.
Me Too.
Just need more attention and people mean to recognize it more and more.
And I think the more wins like the in Ghana when the junior dos Santos wind the
ovary,
man,
it's like he's becoming a superstar.
She's taking a little bit more time.
Yeah.
But the day he goes,
he,
you know,
he doesn't help us sell the fight and like,
well him being a firefighter,
him being the most winning heavyweight of all time,
that kind of helps.
Right?
Like you're saying they didn't help,
what do you mean?
Just say no,
he's not saying he doesn't sell,
he just saying he,
you know,
he,
he does the minimum as far as cell,
like interviews and media just wants to fight and fight fires.
You know what,
man,
there's a fine line that has to be drawn right between how much promotion you do
and how much training you do.
Training has to take precedent over anything,
which is what Steve Bay does.
And she's like,
he's the winningest heavyweight.
Like it's on the promotion.
Yeah.
I also wonder like how much actual travel does versus how much access to him at
his gym,
talking to him at his gym,
you know,
not being able to film any sparring or not being able to film any training they
don't want to,
but talk to him there.
Have uh,
have short interviews that only take place while he's in training camp.
Like,
do you want to talk to him?
Good.
The champ,
we'll meet you for 15 minutes after practice today.
So he just goes there,
he sits for 15 minutes,
he answers a couple of questions from a guy and then he bolts,
he says dark,
so I gotta get Outta here.
I gotta try.
And she goes,
yeah,
he goes in and goes,
does all his recovery that way it doesn't interfere with travel and all that
shit.
Yeah,
I agree.
But,
but also like he shouldn't have to do a,
he's not a,
he's not the guy who's going to give you a sound bite that's going to sell a
fight.
He sends the fight by training hard beating people's ass and he fights fires in
his off time.
I mean being just a unique individual in that regard.
Right.
It's the blue collar.
Everyone can relate to Steve Bay.
More people can relate to steep it.
Then they say Francis
or John Jones,
how many guys are world champions but still have a fucking day job and that day
jobs being a firefighter,
it's actually frowned upon though in the ofc.
Well,
who else has done it?
Chris Lidell did it as Shank Harwin.
Shane Carwyn.
What did was Shane doing?
The engineer,
he worked for the city of Greeley while fighting Brock Lesnar and they begged
them to quit and he wouldn't do it.
Wow.
They actually,
I made him an offer to quit.
I remember being in his car and they made him an offer and he was like,
nope,
can't have benefits.
My kids insurance,
all that it.
Wow.
That's interesting man,
because if you think about it and,
and I get from this,
go see Sam.
If you book from the UFC standpoint,
I get it because imagine if Michael Messy or um,
Peyton manning or Tom Brady had side gigs while they're this world champions
like,
gees,
this is a bad look man.
So you can still be that good,
but you do,
you have to have this job to meet the bills.
Like that's not good.
What if like he worked for the state of Colorado or something,
didn't they?
Shame Gaz it water engineer.
What does state of Greeley,
okay.
Are there a city,
city of Greeley?
Sorry.
Why can they give him some fucking few years off?
You know,
wouldn't that be the move you're saying Greeley just like give him a guarantee
to come back.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I don't know.
It doesn't really work.
Like then the workforce,
like they could probably fill this job with someone who's gonna work full time
now,
but when they love to have a heavyweight champion,
I don't think they give a fuck if you're the Pal Greeley,
you know what I'm saying?
Like it was going to sign some autographs during lunch.
Yeah,
probably right.
I get both sides.
They get shamed.
Especially at the time Shane going,
Nah man,
I gotta look at from a family who knows how long I'm gonna do this.
I'm older.
I have a family to protect that benefits and four zero oneK and all that.
And then Dana going,
dude,
you're fighting Brock Lesnar.
I can't have yet in this job.
And still trying to be the world champion.
Like it's a bad look.
So I get both arguments.
Right.
But for Steve Bay is not a bad look because people,
especially to this day,
like it's a great,
it's a great look in terms of marketing and I love people love first responders.
They hide it though.
Yeah,
UFC kind of hides it like you won't see it on an embedded,
any of that stuff.
They always hide it.
Not really come up put out there now it makes it look,
it makes the sport look bad.
I don't think it does.
He just doesn't want to think it does either.
I'm saying this is from the UFC standpoint where they don't want to get to
having a second job.
But the thing about this fire department,
it's like you get a lot of downtime.
People don't realize how much downtime kind of stuff.
Right.
Well even the way they do shifts,
a lot of times they do 24 hour shifts.
I sleep at the station and work out there.
I had a friend from the pool hall days,
Ray,
the fireman and ray.
The firemen would uh,
exploit name.
They all had weird names.
Like there was like White Plains Charlie.
There was Mount Vernon,
Tommy,
like everybody had weird names.
International South.
Do you have one?
No,
I was Joe the comedian
that creative guys.
It wasn't the crib,
but they just talked the firemen,
firefighters just needed to talk.
Roy Array,
Ray Ray,
the fireman,
firefighter,
firefighter.
He was fine.
He says he was uh,
um,
the first guy explained to me what a great gig it was cause he would do these 24
hour shifts.
He did a couple in a row and then he'd be done for the week and that it stay
there.
Most of the time your bullshit and guys are cooking.
You know,
you work out.
If you like two guys play cards,
that's great.
Yeah.
I love firefighters.
So Ray was like explaining to me,
uh,
like that it's,
it's pretty good Gig,
you know?
But obviously when the shit goes down and the fires burning,
then it's a fucking terrifying.
Yeah,
yeah.
Then it's,
you mean they,
these guys die.
You look at steep like is most like picks a lot of it's his,
him fighting a fire.
Like there's a picture of him,
like he's like going to work and she's covered in ash and he's just like,
damn,
that's a bad,
that's captain America son in a lot of ways.
Right.
And I mean,
Joey Diaz has that fucking amazing,
the amazing a description that an immigrant mentality.
But that is it,
man.
I mean that's him keeping that name too steep.
Amy.
Oh chick.
You know,
that's not like someone changing their name to something that's more compatible
with the modern society mean.
He looks like a Cleveland,
but yeah,
have a look at him.
Look at that fucking animal,
dude.
Monster.
Yeah.
People don't appreciate him enough.
It's unfortunate when it's all said and done.
He's going to be one of the most loved heavyweights of all time.
He'll be like a Jack Dempsey type character.
Even after his career is over,
if people will log them on the UC,
that sports in general,
like right now,
Lebron,
you know the guys hate on him so much or Kevin Durant or Westbrook or even Tom
Brady like these grates on the sport right now.
Once they're gone like holy fuck good.
That guy was Steve Bay's,
that guy.
Like we're not appreciate what happened.
That's when I appreciate and for doom or con or these guys like while it's
happening like that,
fuck this guy,
this guy you pick and choose your battles.
Do you think that it's like,
what is that?
What's that picture logic.
Oh,
boss logic made das boss logic pass artists in the world.
What's going on?
Him and Ted Dose Brac.
I know.
Let's explain what we're seeing and we're looking at a steep bay's body with a
UFC t shirt on,
uh,
like coming out of a fire with a fire mask on fireman's mask on holding his UFC
belt and holding a hose and one hand with the UFC glove on some batteries.
It's so sick.
He's a killer artists man.
It's just,
um,
for whatever reason,
sometimes that happens where guys are overlooked.
That happens a lot of them while they're the king sports,
not so you can appreciate that guy.
After he's gone.
I mean,
I'm like,
Oh shit,
man.
Up Goodi was man slept.
If he beats DC,
he's at shooting for the all time.
Great.
And right now he's,
right now he's basically,
you got to think he's the all time.
Great.
At least in terms of accomplishments.
Let me ask you this,
if DC were to beat steep bays the all time,
great.
He's right up there,
man.
Look,
it's hard to do MMA math,
especially when you got that Jon Jones Wildcard.
That's what's the bomber.
Because if DC beat Steve Bay who's regarded as the greatest UFC heavyweight
champion online,
DC was undefeated heavyweight,
but then he lost to John,
but then he was champion light heavyweight twice.
You'd have to prove the DC is better at heavyweight than he is at light
heavyweight and that would be a hard sell.
What we talking about pound for pound,
we wanted the all time greats.
Unquestionably.
Top three.
Look,
if he goes up and wins,
just in terms of statistics alone,
he'd light heavyweight champion and he beats the heavyweight champion.
The only argument against it would be both times he did it.
It was because John was stripped.
It wasn't because he beat John.
So,
so if that's the problem,
that's like that's a real problem.
I know it's a real per number one.
He's fucking amazing.
You take away John Jones and he's fucking amazing me.
Take Away John Jones,
look at,
he does to rumble Johnson twice.
You know,
look what he does to Gustafson.
Look what he does to everybody.
Everyone gossips and Pfizer war.
There was a war.
I think Gustafson is perhaps the most dangerous challenger to a five right now.
I think Gustafson,
especially if he recovers perfectly from his shoulder surgery Gustafson,
when I saw him fight Glover,
I was like,
this guy is on another,
another level,
another level just to something going on.
I found it.
Yeah.
Any given night he,
he,
you know,
there's kind of,
to me,
I look at light heavyweight.
There's one a one B and one C and it's John at one day it's DC at one B and they
get Dustin at one c after that.
It was love like a motherfucker,
but those three any given night could beat each other I think.
I think you're right.
I think it's fascinating that rumble is not up in there with them.
If you saw the way rumbled destroyed some of those guys,
including Gustafson,
the way rumble just puts the fucking smash on people.
Like when he uppercutted glow over into another universe.
Yeah,
dude,
he's Hayes's scariest guy ever.
And the fact that he just can't get that off on DC,
he's not up there.
As far as the top.
When those Todd,
it's amazing because you be convinced he was.
Did you hear rumbles trend to do bodybuilding?
Do you hear that?
She's trying to go professional bodybuilding.
That's hilarious.
I either heard on out.
Yeah,
I mean fighting.
It's gone.
It's over.
You're going full pain.
What he said after the fight was probably the best way to go for him and I know
he said some different things since then.
Like you said,
he's thinking about coming back as a heavyweight.
Yeah,
and he said like after what fight was it that he said,
let me show these guys how to throw an uppercut.
We'll fucking fight.
Was it was one one fight.
He was tweeting after the fight was over.
Who wasn't Francis over him,
right?
No,
it was a light heavyweight fight.
It was a light heavyweight fight.
I don't remember what fight it was.
Jesus Christ is giant.
Oh my God.
How are we going?
Sizzla oh my God.
Oh my God.
Who's ready to hit the gym?
It's a fight anytime soon.
No,
no,
no.
This is like what?
I don't,
we don't need attached.
You were good.
His,
his fucking carnival bells going to fly higher than mine.
Dang.
Toss those weights around.
That's an interesting career move.
They'll bodybuilding well,
I know he was going into the weed business to what he said after the fight.
I don't think you could ever negate that.
What he said that he doesn't really like the fight.
He's just really good at it.
Correct.
I mean,
boy,
when a guy says that that's just,
that's just,
he's just laying it on the table is who he is and then was the want to do it
anymore.
Yeah.
I remember he had that thing,
but with the La Rams,
I was like,
damn,
what you can do with the rams?
People like that.
He's going to play for the rams and I went on this rant on my show.
He's not playing for the rams
and he DM.
He was like,
Bro,
I'm not playing for the rams moron.
Like he called me one that's me saying,
he's like,
dude,
I'm not playing for the rams.
I was consulting for them with with some performance stuff.
As far as like working out.
They clearly,
I'm not playing running back for the rams.
Clearly you like,
I it know in big dude.
And what does that,
what does he doing?
Oh,
just flexing.
Here's your boy cavitation on the super.
Desi.
What does the shirt say?
No,
I'm saying that Kim.
Where's that weird top can we told you to stop wearing those?
Stop.
Cut your sleeves off camp.
What was the picture above that and she the one that you just had up there
biggest fucking back.
It's just him and his brother.
We Balkan babies.
Come on.
That's ridiculous.
That,
and he's gigantic.
Bodybuilding's itching.
This is going to sound gay.
You know how the greatest back of all time and all of combat sports of all
combat sports.
Hold on,
give me a weight class.
Evander Holyfield.
Oh yes.
And his traps.
His just started.
Oh Bro,
sorry.
The top of his head to fuck my car,
son.
Come on.
So I'm most impressed with combat sports too.
Fucking peaches hanging up the top.
Find it when he fought Tyson,
Evander Holyfield but he fought Tyson.
Just play a clip of that.
You'd finish third or Second Olympia.
He's so Datcher or just that normal skin and just dance.
Yup,
and he was one of the first guys that figured out how to in court prop.
Look at that.
Jesus Christ Jesus,
look at that back.
He was one of the first guys that figured out how to correctly implement a
weightlifting training because of Mackie.
She'll still try.
Everyone thought would make you slower and he was one of the first guys that
really pulled it off and moved up a weight class.
He was the cruiserweight champion has a hard time making one 95 it's like fuck
it,
we're going up and first couple of fights,
I want to say he was like,
you're like two oh five two oh nine and he never got much higher than 11 to 12
yeah.
When was the highest he got?
I was like,
I want to say like two to honey.
Yeah,
some ways at the bite after Tyson bid them.
That was the saddest shit.
Oh,
holy field overall had a better career than Tyson.
Oh for sure.
Two 26 so it probably got up to 10 seconds.
Is that right now that's not,
there's less fighting weight.
By the way.
That's when they used to test you with one of them.
Cracker Jacks rings.
They would just wave it around you and if it didn't show it didn't change
colors.
Yeah.
I don't know if that meant a Funko is shot.
Everything.
Everybody was on everything.
There was no testing.
Get the fuck Outta here with your testing.
I think if Jon Jones was just back then,
oh my God,
the chocolate Dell days.
Yeah,
come on.
So on the Vandelay silver pride days now.
Yeah.
In the early days,
the way the best guys would put it is you never knew who was on anything because
essentially it was an intelligence test,
not a drug test,
because they're only testing the day of the fight.
Most of the guys have already cycled off.
You keep all the benefits for a long period of time and back then they,
you know,
rudimentary tests like didn't have the same kind of test they have
now.
Boom.
We've got,
we're going to fucking traps on Holyfield Jesus son.
It makes Tyson looks smooth.
Dude.
Dude,
he fucked Tyson up in this fight.
I mean,
I remember watching this with Kevin James.
We're in my house in Encino dudes beating the shit out of Tyson.
How great it,
what time was that?
They stopped the fight right there.
It was at the end of the round.
That was the end of the round round.
Oh Dude.
Gimme some volume up on that
bitch.
I want to hear this.
I remember Kevin and I were jumping up and down the couch screaming.
He couldn't believe it.
We couldn't believe it.
Everybody thought like Tyson was the scariest guy ever,
and the only guy that ever beat him was buster Douglas.
And Evander Holyfield was not the same size.
He was coming after him for years trying to make it happen forever.
If you remember,
and a member of Andrew had those crazy fights with Riddick Bowe,
who was enormous guy,
monster,
boom.
Look at this holy fields,
Sun son.
To me,
that right hand,
and it's no disrespect to Tyson.
I have Lennox Lewis and Evander Holyfield,
right?
Yeah.
People forget,
holy,
it was a fucking Olympian man.
Correct.
Did he win a gold medal?
Yes.
Ooh.
Oh no,
he don't
not here.
What did he like?
He got screwed in the Olympics.
Look that up too.
He got spooks.
Boom.
Nobody got screwed like Roy Jones Jr did nobody.
Nobody.
When he fought that Korean dude and the Olympics,
that was one of the worst robberies I've ever seen.
Watching box and have that Irish kid who's fighting.
There you go.
Now they just pushed him back out there.
I mean how hurt
ms he and Tyson charging forward to United just did a podcast on the left ice
around.
He has his own podcast called bite the mic.
Oh Shit.
Oh boom.
God Damn Dude.
Look at the body on a January.
I was first team.
All Bod.
Well,
Tyson just doesn't look physically the same as he did like just coming out of
the pokey,
like he just does not have the same build.
That's it.
Stop the fight.
I'll tell you what you want to fight that.
You know who's just as good?
Anthony,
Joshua Klitschko man jumping.
That was one of the best heavyweight fights ever.
Ever.
I was so much fun,
man.
Let's call gets dropped.
It looks like he's out.
And then he comes back in,
drops Joshua,
and it looks like Joshua was out.
And the Joshua comes back and puts them away later.
Create and now you've got,
you got to Anthony Joshua fighting,
uh,
Parker who's a New Zealand Shampoos,
a monster on defeated.
And then he got wild or fight and Louise or teas and then the winners fight and
hopefully it's wilder verse Joshua Wimbledon [inaudible] 90,000 son or teases a
tough fight for anybody,
man,
I think.
Yeah.
Do you think wilder walks through them?
You know,
I think it stops him.
Wow.
I know Victor Ortiz.
I know the Cuban Olympian boxer.
Yeah.
Really?
What makes you think that?
I don't know.
I'm just not that it's showtime fan boy.
Don't lie.
Well,
they're both showtime.
Oh,
So,
or tease is older and he did piss hot.
He pissed hot.
The,
they're supposed to find hard to do.
Hard to do in bogs.
It'd be trying,
it's hot.
I don't know.
You look at his level of competition.
Nice Wilders,
38 know with 37 knock out,
they maybe hit him with a surprise test.
The thing he tests hot for you to prescription is a little muddy,
but he's test hot before,
but just as a prescription for testosterone wasn't some weird shit.
Deontay wilder is the favorite minus two 35 to Louis [inaudible] one 85 well,
you know what,
man,
when you see odds like that,
you've got to think maybe they know something and maybe Ortiz is,
you know what?
Why was the motherfucker,
we don't know his real age.
You know that Cuban age may be 55 row and no,
that's right.
But also Wilders him,
I'm telling you,
man,
he's a motherfucker.
He's athletic.
He's long now.
He's the all this confidence.
You just the only guy that not to get knocked out to.
He walked through in the first round,
put his hands down,
and I saw that.
That was crazy.
Then he got Anthony Joshua,
who's just,
you know,
the biggest thing right now,
and he's finding Parker's,
it's not a walk in the park either.
There's people like,
oh,
here it is.
There's a stubborn fight.
I still burns.
Never been locked up.
I show that again.
Missed it.
I want to see this.
Boom.
His right hand is something special,
man.
He fights long too.
He does fight long.
He hits hard.
But I just think like Anthony Joshua is not this guy.
No,
no,
no.
What?
I mean,
he's just not,
no,
it's the good fighter.
He's a tough guy.
But Anthony Joshua is a totally different level.
He's an Olympic gold medalist in the heavyweight division.
He's a fucking super stud athlete.
Yeah.
I mean this guy's out of it and while they're putting on a show and beat the
shit out of him and that's all good and it was a great win.
Great Wind for him.
Great.
Does she Joshua's last fight though?
He took it on short notice because it guy didn't make the way it didn't watch.
He didn't look great.
Well,
it was last second.
He fought this guy not up to his level and he went to the decision.
It wasn't really,
yeah,
it wasn't a great fight.
I have that one on my DVR and I never got around to it.
Don't get around to it.
Don't know.
Don't waste your time now it's like it.
Joshua took the night off real and 90,000 do you think that he did that because
he wasn't prepared?
Like cause he tied just to note and I think he was just like,
I could beat this guy in my sleep.
I don't want to risk a lot.
And it's,
you know,
so he did.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
He really didn't,
he didn't push the push the gas on with wild or really doesn't have off nights.
He's trying to smoke.
Everyone is 37 death for God's sakes.
Interesting.
Interesting,
interesting fight.
Well,
we know that,
you know,
wilder can hit hard and we know that Joshua can get tagged and dropped and
recover.
It's such a fun fight for heavyweight.
I just want both of them to say the technical and class.
Right,
man.
Especially in that Anthony Joshua,
he's moving like a motherfucker.
He looked pretty,
just wanted to see Klitschko versus wow.
There.
I thought that would be a really interesting,
but he retired.
Well,
he fought for a long ass time.
Dude.
One of the greats.
Wilder Irish.
Joshua,
if both of them,
when you get that fight,
damn,
every box is good.
Right?
And then don't forget Tyson fury.
He's like,
let's do it.
I'm ready.
I'm all good.
I'm not mentally unstable anymore.
Let's do this happen.
How did he cleaned it up?
He got,
I don't know,
he got his life together.
Started working out,
got sanctioned to fight again now and he even told Anthony,
Joshua,
he's like,
I don't need a warm up.
I'll beat you right now.
And I get guys who train in his gym and goes,
he came in,
whatever.
He was like 400 pounds just beating the shit.
Everyone swapped is just beating the fuck and everybody freak man.
I'm such a big Tyson fury fan man.
Did you see the video of him hitting mitts recently?
Oh,
we're now having to,
he's really fast.
He's a freak really fast.
He's a free like he throws a right hand.
Like look at this.
This is a,
this is not the video that I saw though.
The video that I saw,
but this is,
this is good to the video that I saw was a ham Ma throwing a jab and a right
hand and ducking,
uh,
up and around behind a guy or under and around behind the guy like that,
that little side street.
He's,
yeah,
he's fine,
man.
And his,
his angle,
the sure awkward glitch didn't know what to do with them.
Super confused.
He makes it an ugly fight,
I think for him.
I think,
you know,
Joshua,
it's a nightmare for wilder.
He's a nightmare.
Just because you can't do Kate it.
He's a little fat right here.
I mean,
he's got to keep dropping weight.
But how,
how long ago was that?
One,
2007 November.
Can head movement son.
He's a fucking skilled boxer.
The problem is a guy like him as he starts singing songs after fights and all
the crazy shit that does.
And you,
you just think he's a loon.
Yeah.
But you got to gypsy.
You got to realize like he's super skillful.
Oh,
what'd he could do?
It's very skillful.
I mean Klitschko didn't know what the fuck to do in that file cause she was
like,
what was hesitant show until tell you right hand cause he's doing these awkward
too.
Who's getting popped.
And he realized like this guy might fuck me up.
That's why he's a nightmare for Joshua and wilder.
He's my dark horse because you don't know how to fight a man.
Dark horse.
If he gets his shit together.
Why did he have like psychological problems?
What happened?
I just think,
you know,
he's mentally unstable a little bit and he goes into this depression and he was
world champion.
Then when he got there he didn't know what to do.
He thought it was going to cure all these numbers.
Even defended the title.
I gave it up.
I know that shit's crazy.
Happy and WHATSAPP.
Um,
no,
this is pretty quick too.
It's him.
Um,
there's a guy holding pads for him and uh,
he's just,
doesn't matter.
I mean we're getting the sense of it.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's just a really good fighter.
Yeah man.
Um,
I'm excited about that.
I'm excited about a lot of Shit,
man.
A lot of Shit's going on.
Canelo triple g coming back.
It's very excited.
That's Cinco de Mayo.
They had to do that.
Single my,
I did not do that.
One second.
We got to do it.
I mean,
that's just,
that's just a no brainer.
You could have bet the house on that fight being Cinco de Mayo,
Vegas had the odds that God would it be the Saturday of Cinco de Mayo weekend?
Oh yes.
See you on Saturday.
It's a good time to be a fight.
Fans on inboxing implied in MMA and that's a fight where Canelo has a lot to
prove.
Right.
A lot of people thought he lost the fight and including me,
shady drawl.
I thought it was pretty clear.
I told her it was going to happen.
You did.
You said it straight before anything happened.
He said,
dude,
he has gonna have to knock him out to women decision this than Canelo in Vegas.
I was like,
you think?
Yes,
dude.
Got Roy verse,
um,
Metro drill on this weekend,
this weekend,
right?
Friday night,
right.
It was a Friday or Saturday.
Saturday.
Right.
Pretty sure they,
yeah.
Saturday and then cowboys fight and Sunday,
right?
Yes.
It's a good ass weekend.
Then he also got Mikey Garcia fighting for a showtime.
Ooh.
Racy fighting.
I'm actually going out there to shoot some stuff for,
so to Friday night,
Friday night or a Friday to sick.
Hopefully I'm home in time.
Would you say Rio?
It's Brandon meals.
Yeah.
Real.
It's a good fight.
Let me Brandon real so I'll watch it though.
Hell yeah,
he is.
That's an interesting fight.
Wow.
That's a good boxing match reels verse.
Um,
uh,
God,
Mike Alvarado kicked off all this from Denver.
Yeah.
Might cause another challenge and that kind of story.
Blood and guts type character.
The wild cat.
Yeah.
Denver legend.
You know,
I'm really glad that all this bullshit has died down with boxing versus MMA.
Like there's no,
like you can like both of them now.
You know,
can I deal with all the time because what I'm doing it,
this isn't a weird deal with it.
Did I deal with all the time because especially I can't fish announce it that
there's an announcement coming out Friday.
I got my own show on showtime,
but it does just that.
It's boxing.
It's fighting.
It's UFC.
Delatour,
showtime,
Hbo.
There's no,
there's no agenda.
It's just a like a variety fun show for a fight.
Fans,
entertainment fans.
That's fucking awesome man.
I'm excited.
But I do see that though.
Boxers dammit.
Why does only POCs?
Yeah,
that's what gave me the idea for the show when I pitched the show because when I
was covering the Conor McGregor stuff,
I'd have these boxing heads coming in and like,
what are you talking about man?
Why can't I get out of here?
Stay,
stay in the cage.
I'm in May.
This is the sweet science.
I'm like,
well,
I like both though,
man.
I was a golden gloves boxer.
I like boxing two lights.
It matter.
That's like saying I can't watch the NFL and watch the NBA.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Both.
They get tribal,
everybody gets weird.
Like this is team boxing.
We're team MMA.
It's fun,
man.
It's stupid man.
There was a thing like that with wrestlers in Jujitsu.
People are long,
long time.
Oh Man.
Uh,
when a ensign in UAE arm barred Royce Alger in the UFC and got them in it and
they went and ran backstage Egan anyway,
yells out,
fuck wrestling's
how weird is that?
It was fun because there was,
look,
there's a lot of shit talking going on between all the camps and Royce Alger who
was a top of the food chain American wrestler.
They thought he was just going to run in and storm the fucking UFC and start
smashing people.
And they even said in that fight,
he said it's time to bring in the 18.
Yeah,
that's what he said.
And it's like a little pre fight thing and ensign.
Anyway,
it was like,
yeah,
you guys know,
you know about arm bars cause I fucking sure do.
And and caught him in an arm bar.
Quick CT could find that incident anyway versus Royce Alger hoists but with an
art cause this is an American cat.
And then he lost to um,
what was that dude?
The wolf that do the call themselves to well it's Jackson,
goddammit.
Great name though.
The Wolf Jackson,
those,
those tribes,
those tribes.
So weird though.
Man,
us as verse verse them,
it's stupid.
You don't,
you don't have to pick one.
You knew,
you know he can DVR the box and fight in the UFC fight like you watch all of it,
but a completely different,
they're completely different and there's some things that you can do in boxing
that you just cannot do an MMA.
He can't get it.
There it is.
Ensign.
Anyway.
Royce Alger.
God Damn Man.
What the I,
they had the old fucking,
the guy that was like boss route on the floor,
like the whole deal dude.
And these,
these are the early days.
So this was in 1997 and I was there.
That's is that at,
I don't know if it was in Denver,
man.
It's Denver brother.
You Shields 1997 I sure I [inaudible] in Denver.
Denver.
Are you sure?
Okay.
I feel like it can.
I can then type in [inaudible] 13 j was the second UFC that I worked.
The first one that I worked was in Dothan,
Alabama.
And you don't remember this one when I do not remember what that one more,
I don't know.
I think it's done a lot of them.
When it says the Georgia Augusta,
there you go.
Um,
so this one is a fuck man.
97.
Yeah.
And so Royce Alger takes him down immediately.
And a Anson went on to submit a lot of guys,
including,
he submitted Randy fucking coture.
So stop.
But think of this.
This is a fight at shit.
I don't know what way through we're fighting at,
it says 200 pounds.
Um,
but
Bruce and bastard,
it's still,
see,
hear this,
listen to this heavyweight shoot off.
Wow.
He has a record of eight.
Even then he had beautiful salt,
pepper and look at those traps.
Son and sons,
Jack and Jack Omi,
Yahoo Japan 30 Jackie was Honolulu,
Hawaii,
Japan,
dirty then.
Is that what it says,
gentlemen?
He was already really experienced.
He's also real experienced and had a fucking savage mindset.
Look,
I've checked incentives.
Jesus just skip ahead to how much better he was.
Even good back there.
How much better is he now?
Well now he's just gets fucking site back it up a little bit.
He gets fucking psychotic.
Oh my God.
Look at this.
You got to back a little bit.
Oh,
you wrote it.
It was good to go.
John Mccartney looking slim.
Look at this and say moving forward.
Roy Sal just shoots immediately and to go take his back.
Look at the gear teeth fix attempt here.
Look at this.
Switches it over.
No,
he goes for the other arm.
Wash us.
Here it is.
Oh,
this poor guy has no idea.
Yup.
He just didn't know what to do.
Oh,
we slipped out of that one and he's got um,
risks,
uh,
just risk tape on.
He doesn't have anything.
Covers his knuckles and doesn't,
but Algia does.
So it's smart for Anson.
Like if he was going to get a choke or something like that.
These are the,
these are the days you didn't have to have anything.
Like Royce is wearing shoes.
Look,
he's got some fucking wrestling shoes on.
Remember guys are scanning or wrestling shoes because of heel hook grip on the
hill.
And yeah,
that was a big deal,
right?
Like if you were going to fight in pride,
boy,
you gotta be real careful of those fucking heel hooks.
Especially if you fighting someone like Josh Barnett.
Depending on what phase you're fighting with for doom and pride,
you're going to be in some trouble and consolidate is he catches them from here.
Here comes,
set it up and sees punching with bare knuckle to the eyes and the face.
It's a totally different field.
Right?
It's a different experience.
Completely different.
I'm a fucking giant proponent for bare knuckle.
I really think they should go to bare knuckle.
He just can't fly.
Not past that.
Now we're past that,
but you not because the fingers are all loose.
Look,
you saw this a fight this weekend with the eye.
Gouges.
Let's talk about that.
Look at this.
Whew.
There and goes baby.
Oh,
that's extension.
He just knew how to get out of it either.
This is right here.
This is bill.
That's the shaft that snap.
Super Foxville.
That's it.
That's a fucked up arm broken.
Probably broken.
Yeah.
That's intense shit.
You Act as that jam packed.
Why not barred and Randy fucking coture back in the day.
Yeah.
I remember when he threw these nasty leg kicks from the butts scoop position.
So first time I ever saw somebody throw real good leg kicks from the Butts
Position Gypsy that by standing over him.
Yeah.
But Dude,
he would skip forward on his hand and slam that leg like real power in the leg
kicks like dangerous leg kicks but not thrusts like round kicks.
Yeah.
He would like butt scoot forward and roundhouse kick him in the legs and it's
like,
Whoa,
this is dangerous.
So what was your take on,
uh,
that Matthew's Djing fight?
Look,
dude,
those,
that's me looking at my little cute little face.
There was,
um,
cute little,
those fucking I gouges are bullshit,
man.
They are my only thing with that,
and I'm not condoning this cheap,
but it's like,
I don't know if he knew what he,
what he was poking,
you know?
But when you're in,
when you're the oxygen to your brain is getting cut,
I get it.
But you've got to resist that.
You can't let a guy get away with that.
He'll do it again.
That's the ref.
Yeah,
the right.
But as a fighter it's like,
dude,
I need to live fight another day.
Yeah,
but you don't do that way.
You tap.
That's what trainings are.
Sure.
It's straight up cheating for sure.
Just shady.
It's fucking cheating and they should take points away from him.
He should be sanctioned.
They should sell him.
If this ever happens again,
if we ever think that you're going to do this again,
we're going to kick you out of that school.
Out of the League at the school.
They didn't even give a lot.
Really a warning.
We're going to kick it out of the UFC.
You can't do that.
They did nothing yet.
God's gouge someone's eyes when they're choked.
They did nothing as a fighter happened quicker than I thought.
Maybe if I watched it again for fucks sakes man.
I mean it felt like the eyes were in there.
Let's watch it real quick cause it felt to me like the fingers are in there for
long enough for him to know the fingers.
Matthew's about it.
What does I get it,
man?
It's fight or flight and you're just trying to do anything you can.
Not to tap and go do this thing.
He was like,
you know,
I get it.
I think most fighters can understand how it happens.
I had a coach at her bone go,
dude,
get kind of submission.
You're like guilty and you take your finger,
you run it right up in his asshole.
He goes,
because they might take a point away,
but you live to fight another round.
You're not going to get these,
you know,
tapped out asshole.
POCAN checked down oil son instead of tapping out knuckle deep.
You know,
I tell you who impressed me the most this weekend style bender.
Yeah.
Ooh Dude.
That was some next level shit.
Some great fights,
man style bender put on a show man.
I was,
I've been telling people about him for a long time,
man.
There's a lot of the guys could do for the night too.
You know,
I um,
you know,
after you all look great,
Matthew's look fucking unbelievable.
Looked amazing.
There are some amazing fights.
It was very good the whole night style benders.
A fucking handful for everybody.
Everybody,
everybody there.
There's a lot of dudes practicing their double legs.
Now,
you know,
who's kind of dropped the ball and it was kind of dropped the ball and I'm
again,
I'm on this English,
uh,
bandwagon right now on the train is Deron till like the hype for him set him up,
man.
And he was waiting.
There's all this hype and now it's like the Publix.
Like,
all right,
dude,
let me tell you something.
He's going to be even better.
And they see him again.
He's going to be better,
but we have short memories.
The public has short man.
They'll remember a book,
a man.
They'll remember the problem in the fight.
Nobody wants that get her.
Nelson does.
It doesn't.
Yeah,
that's what we're going to do.
That's the fight.
They booked it right?
When is that for now?
They want to,
because I thought they're trying to do it in London,
but for whatever reason it didn't happen.
Maybe they announced the lending card without a headline can add dare until
headline there.
I don't know why that's not happening.
Well,
he can't headline after one fight.
I could headline Liverpool.
You're talking about a fight night fight night ever pool he's from.
Yeah,
he,
yeah,
he had a headline about,
he's a big fight,
but I mean,
I mean,
I think the dude should be paper view.
They should make that mother fucker a star for sure.
Put him on a big pay per view card.
Put It on Fox.
Jeremy Stephens,
Emmett,
Jeremy Stephens.
God Damn.
I'm enjoying watching Jeremy Stephens.
Stephens Emmett as a headliner,
and you can fucking put Darren till as a headliner.
Here it is.
Boom.
I think it's in here.
I couldn't find a video.
Okay.
He hit him with a right hand.
He heard.
That was a great fight.
Man.
This is a take down.
Here it is.
We'll just count.
There's still three,
five.
Oh my gosh.
Slow motion way is just digging in that dude's eyes.
Yeah.
There's no question.
I know you gotta.
No question about it.
They dropped the ball on that.
Is that,
that's not Goddard.
Whoever it is,
the,
the referee fucked us that ref.
But here's the thing.
We have the video of it.
The UFC should do something.
Someone should do something in the athletic commission so much to do something,
even maybe in Nevada,
you got to look at that and go,
hey man,
you can't ever do this again and we have to find you,
and we have to say,
if you ever do this again,
you should be suspended.
And if you ever do this again,
you get your out.
You can't gouge someone's eyes.
They lose their fucking vision.
One thing,
an accidental.
We can't have any leniency whatsoever towards intentional.
I gouching Sierra Jon Jones and striking.
I don't know if it's intentional.
I mean,
look,
he's definitely putting it.
You're right.
Look,
I,
I'm a,
I'm a one point proponent.
I think every time and I poke happens.
Whether it's intentional or not,
take away a point too.
I think it's a good move.
I think every time that happens we don't go,
hey,
watch the groin case because you're changing the dynamics of that fight.
Every time you bring kicked him nuts,
he was sick to your stomach and trying to fight.
Look at his eyes,
eyes.
There's,
there's literally no warnings.
If you do it.
There's a 0.5 whether it's intentional or not,
you should be getting at the point taken away.
I gouges like that I think is grounds for disqualification.
I just don't think you can allow any room for that because you guys are going to
get to the one blinded guys are going to get blinded.
I mean it could happen and if someone,
if some,
most guys are completely ethical and they would never think of doing this,
but if a guy wanted to,
you start poking people in the eye on purpose.
I mean Roberto Duran did that with Davey Moore.
He thumbed them,
will remember the,
I'm not saying you do it on purpose for our trash brown mat material and Travis
is winning that round,
winning the fight and he gets poked in the eye and that they can't see.
It's a different dynamic.
He loses the fight.
It's happened in many,
many fights,
thank one.
But I think there should be no tolerance if it happens.
Even if you want me do we take a point hundred percent nuts?
We take a point a hundred percent I think kicking the nuts.
First of all,
we should really make sure that the guys are wearing either a tie steel cup or
some,
well timescale cop is like,
that probably shouldn't be allowed to wear cause then that's worse than like
kicking shown in trouble.
That's a problem with our bars,
right?
As a fulcrum.
Yeah.
It gives you extra leverage,
but I don't think they stopped people from wearing it.
No,
like Kenny Florian.
That's what he used to wear.
That's old school,
but yeah,
but that,
look dude,
if you can catch someone and they'll,
you know Damien Maia put on a steel cup in trouble.
Fuck yeah man.
No Shit.
Right.
But those things break sometimes.
Those chords,
hello,
Michael Bisping.
Remember who was he fighting when it's fun come out was that Anderson was a GSP.
Who Was it?
Anderson.
GSP.
He had stuffed it in his underwear and his routes around his cock and balls.
Yep.
That's not what you want.
You don't need that look.
You know,
you don't want that in your life.
That's steel club.
Yeah.
Just loosely banging around against your balls hoping,
thank goodness Jake won that fight.
This,
there's no controversy.
Which fuck yeah.
Like if he did win that fight,
then you've got a problem.
I was thinking of Jake shields and who's smart parts.
Remember that?
That was another horrible,
horrible incident of eye poking.
There should be no,
there's,
there's no warnings,
no tolerance.
I think if you tell John that,
listen,
you touch his eyes,
man.
We're taking points.
Yeah.
He's in close his hand.
So he would be way more cautious.
Everybody,
right?
If you got a free ride to just keep your hand out like that and push guys off by
getting your fingers deepen their eyeballs,
which many guys have done inadvertently.
But if you know for a fact,
if you do that,
you're going to take a point away.
You're going to close your fist up 100% of the time.
But also if it happens more than once,
got a problem.
I'm
not saying to do on purpose,
but your style is a problem for,
for uh,
gin.
Lean.
I get why he was like,
what the fight fight and he's,
he's trying to get out of it.
I get that in the heat of the moment and I'm giving him that be still take a
point away,
right?
There's just,
this should be 0% a hundred percent.
And
when you're doing that,
you know you're cheating when you're doing that.
Trying to get at,
you're supposed to tap,
you know,
either tap or you don't tap.
But if he got out of that headlock or that,
but if you got out of it because the eye poke,
the eye poke kept him somehow or another from a hanging on longer,
that's fucked up and it's cheating.
Cheating to put on style.
See if you can find style bender style vendor man,
don't you think with the UFC.
And I know it's,
it's sanctioned by state to state.
And when,
you know,
with like,
uh,
Eve Levine and a Mazda,
Mario Yamasaki where Dana's like,
he's never,
we don't want him reffing,
never again.
And they don't have a lot of that power.
I almost feel like the UFC needs to start maybe get away.
It's going to be fucking nightmare.
So it's a long path to go down.
But do you know what these commissions,
they almost have too much power.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
in some ways I could see that,
but another way is I could see how you wouldn't want to give the power to the
organization.
You have to give it to the sanctioning bodies that are in the states,
but they all have to catch up.
Look,
it's a fairly recent thing.
If you think about the amount of decades they've been doing baseball and
football,
I mean bomb and may be using the boxing commissions.
That's the thing,
right?
And a lot of these conditions are not that experienced with them.
And may we saw that with New York when we first started doing it in New York.
God,
I mean this was,
they'd just legalized it and then they brought it in and there's a lot of guys
that were local.
They just seem really,
they weren't that good at it.
Like,
wow.
I almost feel like if the UFC had,
you know,
at the performance center,
if they had a judging center referee center and they kind of built their own,
then set them out to the commission.
That's a good idea.
That's a smart idea.
But the problem is the question would be are they independent?
You know,
you have to be independent,
right?
So like Dana White has gotta be able to probably shit on you,
but you,
you gotta be able to keep that from getting you fired.
They're still independent.
I'm just saying the UFC because the,
it's judging is such a big factor in your sport or judge him is different than
refereeing.
Right.
But then play an even bigger problem perhaps because at least the way big race.
Yeah,
the referee seem to have more training and know what they're doing.
There's some,
there's God judging that you just go horrible.
I'm fine reffing in judge and listen because it really impacts a sport.
GC said I were to put a little money and do this.
We're going to train you guys on the sport and then put you out to the
commissions where your own body saying sanction body.
Here's style bender versus Wilkinson.
You know he fits real times in a year.
You know that 20 times in a year,
Japan or some shit and he's so slick.
He does like on a page a little bit interesting.
No,
I don't think so man.
no I'm not.
I'm saying as far as his style and his demeanor,
not,
not as far as the weirdness.
He's much more classic than page pages.
Like a wild more of a karate sport point fighter
who has ridiculous power but with Israel is just vicious technical striking his
movement.
He chops at you,
he knows what you're doing before you're doing it and he's doing a lot of faints
man.
See that?
See that,
see that?
You see that if they made the right leg and then the jab pops one too.
Dude,
that's some high level shit.
But look how he goes from South Paulo Ortho get fourth coffee.
He reminds me,
and again he's not as Lucy and dynamic is Michael van page with his movement and
a lot of the angles that he's using remind me of Michael Page,
but he has better resting,
better grappling,
better take down defense.
Well the big thing is,
is is striking is pure like Moy Tai,
correct.
When you're watching the waves moving,
he uses seminar,
right?
Had you some karate stance.
He goes,
oh,
he's very fluid that,
but look at that fucking knee dude.
This is some high level shit and this guy just wants to take him down to,
and he's a nightmare to deal with.
He through this fucking fake kick and then pop the jab and with zero s there's
no wind up.
You know,
there's no telegraphing at all.
Everything's firing in straight and clean.
And if he can keep these guys off them in terms of his take down defense,
he's a a dangerous guy.
His take down defense looks pretty damn good to me.
What did he weigh in at?
Uh,
he's,
he's a perfect middle weight cause he's not cutting a ton of weight.
Did he weigh one 86 or [inaudible] 85 did he take advantage of that extra pound?
That's where things get interesting.
You know that's not a cut for him though.
Well if it's not a crazy cut from God damn dude,
I mean this fucking guy defense.
It's pretty impressive.
Mckinley but he's fighting.
Got,
he is already fucked up,
but that's at the first round was trying to the exact same shit though.
He could not keep him down.
That's true.
You have saying that Lucy is,
look at that needs is a monster.
It's just the combinations.
What he,
what he's doing is just taking this guy apart.
It's,
he's faking,
he's moving and it's all super technical.
Like there,
I look at this man,
come on,
this is you.
The guy moves towards him and he backs up perfectly and then punish is a more,
and,
and I,
I liked that he's,
he's a seasoned vet.
When you look at his record and what they trying to do to them in Japan,
he's horrible.
Matchups come on,
you're going to be a problem.
He's going to be a problem.
Big problem.
Everybody has confidence.
And they go,
who do you want to fight?
He goes,
I don't care,
man.
I'll beat all these guys.
Whoever wants to come get it,
let me know.
Yeah.
I've been talking to him for years,
man.
When he first started fighting in China,
um,
I started talking to on Instagram.
I'm like,
when are you thinking about coming into the UFC?
And he's like,
I'm,
I'm in no rush.
I'll,
I'll come in when I'm ready and he's fucking ready.
Yeah.
I met him at a UFC maybe three years ago,
maybe four.
Who this guy is being,
not just,
I mean,
this is just,
this is just punishment.
The referee,
so many good fight from him.
Middle Man just kept middleweight.
There's a stopped the fucking nuts and light.
Yeah,
that's enough.
He's trying,
man.
I know,
but do is try,
but he's getting fucked up this anyways,
heavyweight fight.
First of all,
the guy who's fighting to have the biggest I've ever seen,
he just would not leave.
Do they stop this?
He looked like a bad from true lies.
He would not go it.
Yes.
Dot.
That's collapsed.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
he goes,
man,
whatever.
He's like,
yeah.
And he gave himself I think a c minus c minus because he's that good.
That's no joke man.
And he's a nightmare man.
He just got knocked out like last year and a kickboxing match in Brazil and he
was talking about it like real openly online about,
well that's interesting.
It's first time I've ever been knocked out.
You know,
it's interesting the way he talked about the way he handled it.
I was like,
wow,
this guy's got a very junior guilty town about getting knocked out.
He loves it.
Yeah.
It says grace thing that ever happened to them.
So 12 and old MMA,
powerful New Zealand on the map,
12 and oh and MMA.
And if uh,
you bring up his kickboxing record,
I want to find out who's the dude was some,
I don't know even know what organization it was.
Um,
I want to say it was some organization that I know of,
well last two losses,
kickboxing,
make that larger and see what the Brazilian guy's name is and glory.
Alex Perreira.
Oh,
it's in Gloria.
Dude.
Alex Perreira is a fucking beast,
but I think that was a,
um,
Alex beat him twice.
That was a decision.
K.
Oh,
okay.
That's the fight.
Yup.
That's the fight and glory of hero seven.
Was that in Brazil?
Click on that.
Yeah.
Okay.
That was the fight that he talks about on Instagram.
Well,
listen,
Alex Perreira is a fucking killer.
He's,
he's merch and people twice was beat him twice.
How did he beat him in that fight decision?
Right,
so he beat him by decisions and Eko them.
That's just shows you how good Alex Perrera is.
Look,
there's a few guys that are over there that if they just learn how to fucking
stuff,
tank downs,
Giorgio Petrosian might be fucking everybody up.
Give me a nightmare.
Nobody wants any of that shit.
If that guy figured out how to stuff takedowns this kids take down and grappling
looked impressive,
man.
Yes it does and he's going to get better.
I mean,
he's young.
I don't think it's real is only 25 how old is he?
28 okay.
Enough where we as a base for grappling for sure.
That's where he's going to give you look at middleweight division,
man.
Yeah.
He's a motherfucker to fight.
He's,
he's very dangerous on its feet and he's not going to take any stupid chances
and keep going back.
Now I see that mother fucker fight.
Well,
we can easily see Tillen him easily good.
Okay.
Till easily could be moving up to one 85 he's a huge seven giant and with these
new MPO in positions on weight classes,
you know where they're trying to encourage people to find it.
A heavier weight class in California.
You have to do it.
No,
it's still a suggestion apparently.
Oh,
you sure?
Yup.
Novitsky Oh,
[inaudible] said it's still,
I saw this in Boston.
I tell you this.
No,
I was walking to my seat and a,
and he goes,
I'm walking by and he goes,
come on shop.
I looked down,
I'm like,
Oh shit.
Called sketch.
And he started laughing.
I went,
Dude.
And I thought,
I got to tell him I love you by the way.
I love you knew it,
Jeff.
And I go,
dude,
I'm not,
I wasn't trying to be diminishing anything.
Like I respect the shit out because it's all good,
man.
It's funny,
I loved the Vinci too,
but I also,
Lance Armstrong,
I have a real conflict.
I love Lance Armstrong.
Why wouldn't you like when the Wicki comes on the podcast?
Oh really?
Yeah,
I could have it isn't that enjoy it.
Fucking guy went after him and a sport where everybody was dirty.
Yeah.
That's tough.
I mean,
come on.
It's tough.
I'm Switzerland on this,
you guys.
I fucking think it is Goddamn hilarious that they say that Lance Armstrong
didn't win those Tour de France.
They take his name off of it when the,
the guy on the list who tested Nate didn't test positive for steroids.
If you go back to a guy who never got popped,
you got to go to 18th late spot.
So that means everyone he's racing with is geared up to who gives a flying fuck.
He goes setting a bad speech.
You're a psychopath,
correct bill.
Correct.
I mean that's what happened.
He was the best though.
Exactly.
Who Cares?
Well,
they been watch any of this Olympics.
No,
I kind of balls deep in it,
man.
I'm not even touched it.
I'll watch it at night,
might smoke a little weed and I'm just so memorized by a lot of it.
Man.
ICARUS got me,
dude,
I watched that documentary.
I'm like this is just some crazy shit these people are doing.
And I started thinking about it and the really,
the thing that really made me start thinking about it was why the fuck are they
not paying these athletes?
This show is gigantic.
It's worth billions of dollars.
Where's that money going?
Why are those people getting paid?
And the fucking athletes are not getting paid.
And I know it costs a shit ton of money to put on those shows.
I know it does.
Absolutely.
And not as much as the smell,
as much shit brings in no way.
These organizations are raking in millions and millions of dollars to athletes
aren't getting a penny of it.
The two most corrupted things in America,
but all around the world.
The Olympic sports and call college football,
college basketball.
So Fuck College basketball and college football.
It's so crazy.
Especially cause they're taking damage.
Oh Dude.
It's so,
it's essentially a combat sport.
And a lot of ways,
right?
I mean,
you're running at each other,
you're trying to do war and trying to get your fucking football crops align.
They're trying to stop you.
You've got a team of aggressors going after their team.
You're clashing into each other.
What were fighting?
Yeah,
12 to 14 times a year.
and you can't,
if I can't hit each other in terms of punches and kicks,
but you're running at each other full blast wearing helmets.
You need each other harder.
Whole body and your body like a spear to Jamie showed me a highlight reel of
dudes getting KOD and football done in reverse.
It's horrible.
It's the reverse thing.
I'm not a big fan of,
I'd rather watch it.
My brain has a heart.
My stupid brain has a hard time processing.
I don't see how I want to watch it in full speed or in slow motion.
You see how the impact,
we see the helmets flying.
Horrible.
See the dudes laying on the ground,
their eyes rolled back in their head.
It's a different level of Keio too.
So running Kaos level to this game and soap,
like in the super ball,
homeboy got knocked the fuck out in the super bowl.
It's vicious,
man.
It's crazy.
It's weird.
I'd let my son play football and not let them fight.
That is weird.
It's weird,
right?
Cause football,
you know,
he could get to get into Stanford,
get an education fighting.
It's,
it's,
there's no benefits.
No God damn dude.
And you're sure as fuck not coming out of,
you know,
you don't hear and fighting this corner out of the Palisades.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just not,
it's not worth it.
That's true.
But he could be a great Jujitsu fighter if he hates money.
Yes,
he could do Jujitsu.
Dedicated his life to that.
Why don't you just dedicate yourself to coming up with a Jujitsu league that's
profitable?
I guess I could take some time and do that.
If jujitsu gets more and more popular,
like how much it would already hit.
Joe,
what does,
um,
I don't necessarily know if it's done it.
It would a kid caught on by now.
Yeah,
I think so.
I think it's more popular than ever.
What I want to know what is more pop way?
I think that,
I still think it,
it might be,
you know,
I don't think it's ever going to be like a mainstream,
like big,
like guys making millions of dollars it would already hit well,
Ebi is probably the biggest one for sure.
And she's the best by far the best program to watch for sure.
Because of the,
um,
the overtime system.
Yep.
But do people know enough about it to appreciate it?
It takes too much time to invest in knowing the sport.
What about combat?
People don't care.
Combat Jujitsu's ways and I just watch fucking MMA.
You see bitch slaps
pitch slide.
I'm going to watch MMA if I want to see hitting on the ground.
That's true.
But I feel like it's a lab for learning what techniques are applicable to MMA
before you actually get into MMA?
Basically all the same principles apply.
If you could slap somebody in the face and you see slow,
like we're okay in this position.
This guy is very open to face for slap.
So if this was punches,
it'd be a way worse situation for him and some guys can get stopped with slaps
like Wagner Rocia duty.
Who did he stop?
He stopped.
Um,
but,
but when you think,
when you think about from theme about the crowd's booing the UFC fight,
when it goes to the brand orchard,
when,
when like when it could be thank beaten the shit us I on a steep based like Ooh
and Francis and steep and when he's beating the shit,
I'm now think about Jujitsu slapping.
Like it's never going to correlate to the mass.
It's just not,
I enjoy watching it.
I'm aware though.
But you know what's interesting though,
they didn't boost Khabib cause could beams mauling was so terrifying that you've
realized like nobody was like boom,
stirring them up,
standing him up.
No.
Cause it could be,
but just beating the shit out of him the entire time their dad's beating the
shit on.
But if you look at the,
the viewership on that,
it's not crazy where people are like that.
No one's going,
you got to tune into the guy's beating the shit items presented.
The paper view wasn't a paper view that fight that fight,
but fight was that,
those can be paper views.
And who else was on that?
I called the fight.
So it had to be paid for if you correct.
Who else was there?
Might've been on,
no,
it wasn't always picks on the car,
right?
Yeah,
it was the good one.
What is it on to 19 so as to,
was it the Khomeini?
December one was it the co main event?
It was a phenomenal fight.
Was that Cyborg?
That was Cyborg cyborg versus Holly Holm and the final correct.
Is that what it is?
A pretty sure set it a couple of one,
two punches,
but still like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like maybe 400,000 people saw that.
So write for the paper you no one's calling,
dude,
you've got to tune in this,
this Russian or because we're different.
Kazakhstan Dagestan Dagestan is beating the shit out of this Brazilian.
Like it's just not,
that doesn't translate like a Forrest Griffin and Stephan Bonner fight.
Unfortunately.
You have to tune in and buy this paper if you'll see it's way easier to get,
especially when it's a Comeya van already.
Man,
it's hard to get people to buy in that late,
in a fight like dilate and the card you already made to the co main event,
it's already going on.
What's the next fight?
Oh,
it's a cyborg versus Holly Holm.
Uh,
I'm going to watch it on the replay.
You know,
once you're already dead,
he deep in the card.
Yeah,
it's a little late.
If it's on Spike TV and you call your friend up and you go,
dude,
you got to watch these crazy white boys beat the fuck out of each other and
doing that then could be to do that.
People aren't doing it.
It's not going to,
I'm not calling my dad when you got to tune in.
See could be beat the shit on this guy.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know if that's true because if that fight was on Fox,
I really feel like people would have went crazy if you saw the way it could be
kept taking Edson Barboza down a mall in them.
The way we were calling it,
the ratings would side with me.
This year's ratings would definitely say it can be fun on Fox.
He's there.
He's at fights on,
he's at fights.
He hasn't,
all his fights haven't been on paper view.
Yeah.
Who's had fights on fs one,
right?
Like Darrell Horcher.
Did you fight him on?
Um,
he's had some fights on his fighting style is in the type of fighting style
where it crosses over to the masses.
We love them because it's beaten the shit out of people on the ground.
He's also one thing that people love and that's undefeated,
undefeated and I think he's 18 and now.
So it was not asking though.
He a big shot in the UFC.
His last two fights before or the FiberForm Michael Johnson.
We fight dos Anjos and Horcher.
We're both FC on Fox events and how and how much trading.
Interesting.
And he beat the fuck out of Dos Anjos.
He did pay fucking breaks off of it and Horcher was a real last minute
substitution.
I mean
it's tough.
It's fucked up.
What about Michael Johnson?
Was that Fox where he's telling them to see to a five.
Okay.
That was a terrible one.
Jim,
he's telling you about.
He was give up.
I get a title shot out of a monster and bang.
It's a fucking killer son.
Um,
but he needed this fight because he needed to fight where it was post weight
loss bullshit.
Like the,
with the weight cut where they had Tony's got a real nutritionist now it looked
way better.
I'm very excited about that height and GroupM.
Tony Man,
very,
very excited about it.
I can't find a venue to do a show.
It's too late.
What?
I know it's going to show Thursday night before yours.
I know they can't find one.
Gotham's booked.
Well,
I was going to do one night.
Caroline is,
but it's too small.
So I'm just come back,
do a weekend in New York and said,
boy,
you have to work with me.
I would love to,
man.
All right.
We'll do it that they let me know.
I worked with you.
You work with health,
Dude.
I'd love to tell me.
All right.
We made it happen.
Hey,
um,
what else going on?
We,
it's almost five 30.
Did we cover everything we have man,
right.
Forever.
Things go by fast,
but three hours.
I think we talked for three hours baby and we'll wrap bitch up.
Um,
so,
uh,
can't talk about that other thing to showtime stuff.
You talk about some things.
I have an exciting,
yeah,
it's exciting announcement.
I'm saying this,
I got my own TV show coming out with showtime.
It'd be on digital end.
That network on showtime does certain things.
You can't say.
Yeah,
we'll write.
Now they have to make the official announcement.
Oh,
we've got all the contracts in place,
but they want to make the official now you already fucked them over.
Then by saying it right here,
they told me I could say it.
Oh,
they just,
I can't say the exact thing,
but next weekend I'm at La Jolla comedy store,
Friday and Saturday,
one of the greatest clubs in the history of the club.
That's a great spot.
It's as good as the comedy store in Hollywood best.
So on there.
Friday,
Saturday night,
all those tickets are almost sold out.
Two shows,
Friday,
two shows Saturday,
and then march.
I'm in Tampa,
Palm Beach and Orlando Son.
Powerful Brendan chubb.com how much should be powerful Brennan shop?
Why don't you change your website?
That's your powerful,
powerful,
powerful.
In front of our nights,
whoever you are,
powerful in front of your name,
you feel better about your life,
your later right later fuckers
best.